那个今天这一讲的话呢
我们会继续讲渲染
那么这一讲的话呢
其实也是我自己认为是难度最大的一家
我们整整爆肝了一个星期吧
然后说实话
我到现在虽然写完了整个课件
但是我并不是特别有信心
我们能把这一讲解好
为什么呢
因为这一讲的内容实在是太大了
如果说我把今天这一讲的内容
分成十节课来讲的话
我认为也没有什么太大问题
那么今天这讲什么呢
我觉得就是讲绘制绘制最核心的
绘制的核心是什么呢
其实像上一节课我们讲的就是A材质对吧
讲到这个材质啊
那个mesh啊
包括一些GPU
你怎么怎么去组织管理
听上去好像都非常有道理
但其实这些道理呢
你把这么多数据放在这
你让GPU去做
但其GPU到底怎么做呢
他需要绘制
那这里面的绘制的第一个主角是什么呢
就是光光的核心就是光子
就是光子发射出来反射被吸收反弹
最后进入我们的眼睛
形成这个事件的光的原理是什么
那么第二个呢就是这个光和材质
就是和物质到底怎么反应对吧
我这物理是当你把你光是反弹回去
还是把你吸收进去
还是再让你在我里面转来转去
那么你的这个物质和光是怎么反应
这件事情又决定了这个东西
我们看起来是什么样的
那么最后一个的话就是说
我们我们的SHADER该怎么去写
有很多复杂的运算
所以其实这节课讲的这个东西啊
就是说我们讲lighting material shader
就是光材质与这个着色器
实际上是一个非常庞杂的一个系统
我自己啊竭尽所能把它挤进去了
但是这一节课的课件长度
已经接近100页左右了
90多页
我记得好像有90多页
然后其实我自己有感慨啊
就是我我写完这个课件的时候
跟我们的团队在一起
我学着我们是把过去几十年
就是全世界最聪明的这些理论学家
就是图形学的这个科研工作者和工程师在一起
各种非常惊人的聪明的想法集结在一起
但是这里面有很多大胆的讲
假设非常这个我认为叫厚颜无耻吧
这个打个双引号
就是说基本上是什么都不管不顾的
各种hack放到一起
他居然就work了
然后就终于形成了我们这种
非常棒的这个游戏体验
所以说啊这节课的话呢
我觉得我们就是虽然讲的东西非常的硬核
而且中间我首先高能预警一下
会出现很多
非常非常这个这个看起来让大家头疼
肚子疼的数学公式
但是呢大家可以当成一个故事来听
就像我我我是我跟大家讲
我是一个很民间的民间的物理的这个爱好者嘛
就典型的民科思维方式
所以我最喜欢的一本书叫量子力学300年对吧
他就是把这个人类认知怎么怎么从简单到复杂
一步一步的去建立
这样的一个一个就是对对世界的本源
认识的越来越清楚的过程
这中间就是各种的观点的碰撞
各种人的想法在一起打架
这事读起来津津有味
所以我我其实今天在写这一趴的时候
我基本上说那来这样吧
既然硬核的知识讲不了太深
那我就跟大家讲个故事吧
所以呢首先的话呢
我们就从这个故事的原点开始
这个这是最著名的
就是渲染最核心的那个我们的宗师吧
叫柯基亚
那卡西亚的话呢
这个这个是个日本老哥
日益老哥
我不是
我忘了
他是在美国大学教书
还是在还在日本工系统
好像是在在美国
然后这这位我们的大圣
那个我们的先贤在35年前就提出了
那个时候sf大家记住了
那时候sf好像还没有电子版
我印象特别深
好像是那种打印出来的版本
我觉得是惊为天人
然后呢老人家就写了一组方程
说唉呀同学们这个全世界所有的渲染
用这一个六维方程方程基本上就讲完了
你们就就膜拜吧
其他的事情你们就不用想了
这个方程看上去很高大上啊
但其实也蛮简单的
你仔细看他说呢
就是说你在一个点
你去观察一个物体的表面任何一个X点对吧
这个点可以是啊二两维的点也可以
三维的点
这个多少具体多少维度要数一下了
那么你首先有一个观察角对吧
就是那个欧米伽O
那就是你人的observer的观察角
那么首先的话呢那个点它是不会自我发光
他如果自我发光的话
那他在omega那个O的那个角度射出来的光
肯定会让你看到
对不对
好第二个呢他得加上什么呢
加上说这个点
如果被很多其他的周边的光源给照上了
去的时候
它会最后反射出来会是什么样的
一个一个一个一个一个结果
那么这个时候它就是一个呢积分项
就是说从所有可能的球面上的入射角
射出来的光
然后呢它投影到你的表面
这里面注意要乘上一个cos theta
这cos c塔是什么东西呢
就是说你可以理解成就是如果光斜着照过来
同样的光强
你的表面上能接受的能量是不是会越来越低
这件事情听上去好像很这个cos西塔很高大上
其实呢去理解它其实非常的简单
比如说太阳光照到地球是不是无差别的
对不对
那为什么在纬度高的地方就会冷
纬度低的地方就会热呢
因为在同样的单位面积上
纬度高的地方的话
它乘上了一个就是你的那个那个高纬度的那个
球面上的那个那个就是我们的垂直向
就其实就是法向和太阳光的那个角度
那如果在极地的时候
那cos theta几乎为零对吧
在那个赤道的时候几乎为90度
所以呢你接收到的能量就会很高
然后呢这个时候有另外一个方程
我们叫scattering function
就是说呢他会跟你说
哎你在这样的一个入射角下
在这样的一个出射角下
你大概有多少能量能够被反射回来
这里面到底发生了什么
很奇怪的就是光电子反应
那个就是卡基亚同志呢也没解释
但是说这肯定是一个思维方程就能解决了
这个思维方程呢就是这个最著名的
我们叫做BRDF叫双向
这个那个反射分布方程对吧
这个是让我们所有做图形学的同学
做graphics engineer的同学
都是这个叫什么叫魂牵梦绕
这个这个就是既向往又害怕的这么一个方程
所以凯基亚同志的话
这个这个六维方程
基本上就把渲染的东西全部讲完了
对不对
这个是将近35年前
但是呢这整整35年
我们整个行业就被这件事情搞得死去活来
那为什么呢
因为真实的世界的光照非常的复杂
就是大家看这张图吧
这张图的话也是一张很经典的图了
他就跟你讲说
你看啊
我就画这么简单的一个书桌的一角
你看到它有直接的光线照在我的书桌表面
变得很好看
对不对
变得很亮
然后呢
有些地方它呢就是那个光会被一个物体挡住
它会形成一个我们叫做shadow阴影
对不对
大家玩游戏的时候
最在乎的就是这个shadow做的好不好
这个阴影其实比大家想象的非难很多
好这事我们就忍了诶
但是这个光呢你打到这个很多表面
它又反射了
反射了之后
它本身又变成了一个光源
又照亮了别人
这就很蛋疼了对吧
这个就是我们在那个有个很著名的说法
叫COLORBBLEEDING
就是比如说你这个反射面如果带颜色的话
这个颜色还可以去反射出去
然后呢你还有一些非常glossy的物体
它本身像个镜子一样的
就直接反射回来了
然后呢还有一些半透明的物体
光在里面就是做了reaction
就是在里面折射
做了好多次光机又出来了一下
那你想这么多东西
这么多效果
这个你说它符不符合科基亚老先生的方程呢
是非常符合他的方程的
但是呢问题是我怎么解对吧
而且我所有的东西必须要real time的去解它
这就是我们的挑战
那这里面呢我们很难的点是什么呢
就第一个就是以下的这几个挑战
是我纯个人总结的
就是我我得声明一下
就是因为呃
很少有人像我对这个老先生的这个方程这么的
就是不能讲是不公吧
就是内心充满了这个抱怨
就是说老先生你只是给我们指了一条路
但这条路怎么走对吧
我要带什么道具
这个带什么
带多少干粮
你都不告诉我
然后我我在这饿得死去活来
累得死去活来
所以呢我我就借用这个课程
小小的向老先生表达我的这个作为一个学徒吧
就觉得师傅帮我不够的这种抱怨
那我第一个抱怨的就是说老先生
你有没有意识到
其实visibility to light就是你一个点
你告诉我有个光
我能不能看见他这件事情其实并不简单
那么这个visibility to light呢
从我们大家最熟悉的方式解释是什么呢
那就是shadow阴影对吧
就是这里面讲一句
这个我在在在这个就是课程上不敢写的话
这个里面就是政治不正确
就是以前在我们游戏行业里面
有一个非常资深的一个一个图形学的大佬
他讲过一句话叫shadow beech
就是说阴影实际上呢是计算机图形学里面
最常用的一个效果
但是呢几乎所有的graphics engineer
他告诉你说
我在做几乎所有的游戏的时候
shadow想做的好
那都是非常非常难的
有大量的hack
而且你解决了情况
A情况BCD可能就要出问题
所以就这么一个简单的visibility
Visibility to light
就解决了我们死去的活来
那么但是呢这个东西这个效果可可不可以没有
那显然是不能没有的
因为你一旦没有了阴影之后
大家看到这个就这右边的这个图的话
那基本上这个空间关系会让你产生很多的错了
因为我们很多时候是利用这种明暗的遮挡关系
人员的大脑是判断它的层次结构的对吧
那么这是我称为叫这个第一组挑战的
第一个挑战
道光的可见性
第二个挑战呢是大家不太注意到的
但实际上又是非常常见的
就是这个光本身啊
它很复杂
为什么呢
因为我们想几个最简单的光源吧
比如说那个方向光源
比如太阳在无穷远的地方照过来的
其实它不是无穷远
那我们可以假设太阳光是平行线
这个呢还简单一点
然后呢接下来来了一个就是点光源
点光源其实也还好
我们也有办法能处理
然后呢路灯下大家经常见的什么是一个spotlight
就是一个锥形的光源
就是大家也很常见对吧
但是呢突然给你来一个叫面光源的时候
你会发现这件事情就变得非常的复杂了
而且面光源也就意味着说
当我一个物理我接受的光照的时候
你你同样有光什么强度变
我把那个光源自身转来转去的时候
你会发现下面的东西完全就变掉了
那么其实光源本身它也具有一定的复杂度的
这个是很麻烦的一件事情
所以这就是我我觉得它的方程
这个就是IRRADIANCE
就是进来的这个光给我的挑战哦
忘了给大家讲个概念了
就是这个在我们图形学里面呢
大家一定要学两个黑化
一个叫做radiance
一个叫ERENCE
先讲radius是什么
radius呢实际上是叫辐射度
或者叫你辐射出去的能量
就是它源自于黑体辐射的逻辑
就是说比如说我一个光照到物体上
它往外反射出的能量叫radius
对不对
那好那入式的能量呢
我们以前叫做incoming radiance
但是呢我们把两个词合到一起了
叫一瑞典
就是入射的能量
那么在球面空间上
我们的整个reading的分布
或者这个它的信息的获取
其实呢这在我看来是第一组挑战
这个挑战已经很麻烦了
那么第二次挑战是什么呢
就是老先生讲这个材质那个方程
大家看下面那个方程啊
我是要在整个球面函数上跟对
把它的这个光和他的那个就是BRDF模型
那个四维函数在一起去积分
同学们想一想
这个是不是很头疼
非常头疼对吧
当然我可以很粗暴的用这个那个数值的解法
就是一个个采样
我一个个解
但是大家想象一下
在实时的时候我怎么办
我做不到
对不对
那我怎么样能够快速的去算出
这个光和我的材质之间的这个卷积的
这个结果呢
这件事情其实很麻烦
非常麻烦
我后面会跟大家具体讲到
所以这其实是我们第二条
就是说如何做
用一个graphics的话讲
就是你如何做shading对吧
我我告诉你光了
我就把整个球面的光我都告诉你了
那你把这个材质的效果做对
其实这件事情也并不简单
那么这是我的第二个材料
就是积分怎么做
那么第三个呢也是让我个人觉得头疼
肚子疼的东西
就是说其实在一个真实的世界里面
所有的物质它本身就是光源
为什么呢
就像这张图讲的特别明显
就是你的地面上那个点
你光直接照到我了
OK我亮了
没问题对吧
这个时候呢你打到墙上
那个墙上又会bouncing回来
又把我照了一遍
然后呢你再bouncing1遍
再别BING1遍
两遍又把我照了一遍
就是它可以一次BANCING
二次BANCING
所以在图形学中有一个很著名的案例
大家可能已经就是如果上过101课程
202课程的同学们应该知道叫康奈尔box对吧
这是我们图形学最经典的一个一个案例
这个里面的话
两边为什么有两个不同颜色的墙呢
他就是告诉你说
光在这里面来回的几次bounce之后
它会形成一个非常复杂的光影效果
所以其实我们在做渲染的人
经常会拿康纳box说
This is ground truth
就是这是拿真实的算出来的结果啊
这是我一个hack的算法
跟他之间side by side进行比较
看看我们能够逼近它多少
所以其实这就意味着什么呢
在场景中我们有无穷多个可能的光源
所以这三个挑战在一起啊
其实对我们来讲是一个很大的折磨
当然我这里面得声明一下
就是这纯属games4104课程
就是这个我我自己私人的
私家的这个总结的三点挑战
但是可能每个人说法不一样
但是我自己做rendering做了就是很长时间之后
我自己感觉最痛苦的事情
第一个就是说你对incoming的那个ERIS
实际上我很难去得到它对吧
我如果得到了沙的问题
我就解决了
第二个的话呢就是包括那个面光源的问题
第二个的话呢就是光源我全部拿到了
但是呢我去磕我的表面的材质
进行做这个CD运算
它是个积分运算
这事情又让我很头疼
那第三个呢就是说哎因为光是可以被弹出来的
所以的话呢你光一旦开打开之后
场景里每一个物质都是我的光源
这就意味着什么呢
这就意味着说你第一次计算出来
那个每一个每一个物质的
它的那个就是light的output
就是它的输出实际上要作为下一次的输入了
所以这里面是一个无限递归的东西
所以说问题三又会把问题一变得更麻烦
这个简直就是一个恶性循环
所以说呃在最早的时候
我们在做这个场景光照的时候
有个很出名的算法叫retracing对吧
那么retracing呢
你们还有一个方法就是基于这个叫啊分布教师
distributed retracing嘛
我记得那个算法就是它最大的问题就是你一颗
你一跟瑞打出去之后
他得不停的发散发散发散发散
最后那个rain就会爆炸掉
但是现在没有人真的这么去写了对吧
这么写的话呃这个就算是离线
他也扛不住
但是呢我讲它但它确实反映了光学着
它本质是这样的
因为我经常讲一件事情
就是说上帝它的存储空间
它的算力是无限的
所以它可以用最简单的风头去解决这个问题
但是呢到了我们这种graphics engineer的时候
我们会需要在非常有限制的这个这个计算机上
去模拟他老人家做的事情
所以这这这这个地方呢就是我个人的总结
就是卡基亚老先生
把这个render equation扔出来之后
我们折腾了我们才30几年
实话实说
到今天的话
我们也没有完全解决他老人家汽车的问题
但是我觉得现在看到了一些希望的苗头
我后面会讲到
就是说那接下来我要讲今天我们的正题了
就是how to do这个rendering in the engine
那这件事情的话呢
其实后面会讲到大量的公式会越来越复杂
那我在写这个课件的时候
我就想一件事情
我说其实当年我在学图形学的时候
我在学最开始做游戏的时候
我真的需要学那么多复杂的
这个什么BRDF模型对吧
各种球面调和函数
各种什么积分对吧
这个这个信号的这个从这个各种信号的转换
好像也没有
其实我最开始写这个游戏引擎的渲染
包括写渲染算法的时候
实际上是非常非常简单的
所以而且呢这会会帮助我们建立一个
非常清晰的
这个就是说引擎的它的渲染的基础流程是什么
后来我想那这样咱们这个课也是这样的
因为这个课games焦虑四课程的这个课程的话呢
我希望是能让越来越多的人能听懂
所以呢我觉得咱们也不要好高骛远
先从最简单的开始
就是最最简单的渲染是怎么回事
那首先的话非常简单嘛
这个世界我先去简化它嘛对吧
你不是光滑很复杂吗
那我就用最简单的光源形态
比如说我第一个叫主光dominant light对吧
那我给它设置一个
你要么就是一个方向光
要么就是个点光
要么就是一个这个spotlight
一个一个一个就是那个叫柱状
那叫什么叫圆锥追光追光
感觉有的时候脑子反应不过来啊
然后你你的球面上不是有很多的这种广场
我不知道嘛
哎我第一个东西叫做ambient light
ambient light是什么概念呢
就是说我假设把这个主光刨掉之后
环境给我的光
我可以用一个他的命
就是它的那个平均值代替
那我是不是可以得到一个叫AMBNOL的
这个东西对吧
大家四面抛来的光
我就就是用一个数值把你带到了第三个呢
哎我这样的话
其实这个东西最牛逼的一件事情是什么呢
就是说在最早的硬件上
完全支持了他所有的所有的光的这个这个效果
那这个时候我的我其实这个时候东西会输出来
已经很像那么回事了
诶我还不满足
我想一想这个环境中
可能我假设我的这个物体表面
它是个非常光滑的东西
它是不是要来反射一下环境
其实这个时候呢它既不是主光
但是黄金的一条光正好跟你的就是它的那个啊
就是我们的最著名的那个
就是你的你的那个入射光的方向和
法线和那个反射光的方向正好和法线的重合了
对不对
那我要看到一个很漂亮的反射
那我们想了一个简单的hack
我们研发了一种东西叫做什么呢
叫做环境贴图
大家有没有印象它是一个六边形的
就是大家想象一下
我一个立方体
我把它切出来是不是正好六个面
对不对
那个六个面的话叫环境贴图
好
我根据我眼睛看的角度
我呢根据你表面的法向我反射一下
砰
在那个那个包着的那个
这个这个大的方形盒子里面找到那个点的图
诶
这个又把我的那个就是广场那一部分
也表达清楚了
那这样的一个简单的组合的话呢
实际上大家回到这个卡基亚老先生的方程
你会发现
虽然我们用了最最简单的方法
但其实我们是符合它的方程的
本质上
我们把一个半球形的这个光照光场的分母
把它模拟成了一个均匀的环境
光的一个入射光
再加上一个突出的dominant light
然后呢在环境过程中一些高频的东西
我用一个environment map把你表达了
这样的话呢
我把你BRDF中特别敏感的那个spectra
那一项给你反映出来了
但这里我提前讲解一下什么叫SPL
大家想想这个是不是就是我们在学数学的时候
我给你一个通用函数
你去求它的积分
求它的解析解是很难的
对不对
通用的方程
但是的话呢我一旦把方程参数特例化之后
诶这个方程我就能求它的解析解了
其实最早的这个我们的graphics engineer的话
没有被卡基亚老先生给忽悠
我们想你你的方程牛逼
我觉得你都是对的
但是呢我们很土
我们写算法的人
我们写硬件的人
没办法
我们就用这种最土的方法去解决了
所以这是最早的这个光照模型
我们就用这种方法去解决了
那么好
接下来就是材质了
对不对
材质这件事情呢就非常的神奇了
如果大家有机会去研究一下这个整个材质的
就BRTF模型发展的历史啊
那简直就是百花齐放齐放
各种理论
现在最前沿的都已经到了
这个光的波动理论
就是讲这个光之间会互相干涉衍射了对吧
这个绝对的高大上
那个数学公司看的你绝对是这个
这个觉得
我恨不得大学回去再去多练两个专业专业
但是呢其实在材质模型中
有一派是我特别特别喜欢的一派
叫什么呢
叫做经验派
就这帮人是这样的
就是他也不去研究你
物理空间到底的本质是什么对吧
第二个呢我也不做实验
说这个实验
我去真的拿我的模型跟你的实验去进行比较
我就根据我的观察
我觉得哦材质是有什么呢
诶有这个漫反射像对吧
就是说你一个光打进来
我四面八方看起来好像都是一样的
漫反射像还有什么呢
还有那个诶很很亮的那个反射
就是说诶我这有的有的表面非常的光滑
油的表面呢
它非它它这个这个反射的loop叫NOLOB
loop的话呢它相对比较缓慢一点
大家想一想
看在数学上什么方程能够让我一调
我就能够把那个反射的那个那个波
把它调的变宽变窄了
其实最简单粗暴的就是这个power函数
就是几次幂对吧
你的一次幂
二次幂
三次幂
四次幂
那你的这个函数摔的是不是就是越来越抖
越来越越来越宽
诶
就用这个方法
所以呢
这个这里面就必须要说说
我们的大名鼎鼎的布林风模型了
那么它其实是非常非常的简单
就是说ok defuse
他就说用cos你入射角
然后呢我就把你的光的能量那个算一下
然后我就把你反弹出去了
但是呢我和我一个反弹率
因为有些能量可能在我的内部被吸收掉了对吧
我可能我只能反弹这部分能量的
比如说20%
30%
40%
那么呢你还有一些特别漂亮的东西
我用那个sparkler把你冰给你反射出去
让你看上去很像金属
很像那种光滑表面的感觉
就我有我们看到的高光
那用两个简单的方法加到一起诶
我们就能形成了这样的一个材质模型
所以不吝风模型的话呃
说实话虽然它很简单
它很粗暴
但是呢我直到今天我还是觉得非常的亲切
比如说今天假设我要去教图形学课的话
我会让我的同学们先去实践一下
bling phone这个模型
那么其实在这个BINFO模型里面啊
这也体现了一个非常简单朴素的光学原理
叫什么呢
叫光可叠加原理
其实刚才我在讲的那个卡基亚方程的时候
也忘了说这件事
就是它那个方程
为什么你的出射光和他的这个所有的光
都能够积分起来
就是这是光学的一个基本假设
就是说我的所有的光不管你是来自于什么地方
我最后都是可以用linear的线性的叠加在一起的
那么这个bling phone的这个模型的话又简单又好用
但是它的问题是什么呢
其实有两个比较大的问题
那第一个问题呢
这个问题在最早我们做那个
就是说游戏渲染的时候
还好
我们其实无所谓的
但是呢如果你用不灵风模型做一些真正的
就是比如说离线渲染的时候
你就会发现点出问题
为什么呢
他的那个能量其实是不守恒的
也就是说在这边你你在那边写的时候
那个那个SPARKER的参数
diffuse参数
包括SPER那个power
你会发现你的入射能量
最后通过它的方程反弹回来得到的出射能量
这个能量可能会比如说超过一
就是你进来能量是100份出来
假设是101份
这个听上去好像还可以
对不对
你人也注意不到
但是如果你假设真的做了一个
就是光线追踪算法
在这个在这个里面
它会无限的进行来回反弹追踪的时候
你就会发现这个震荡就会放大
所以刚才你看这个在左边的这个图里面的话
就是一个retracing
如果用blink phone的话
里面本来是应该一个黑枪对吧
但是呢只要有光漏进去之后
他在里面就开始无限无限的来回倒
倒了之后
反而内部的东西反而变亮了
这个在一些离线渲染的时候
就是要要人命的事
要出事的东西
所以我们有一个说法叫做energy conservative
那个a conservation
那么很多很多人把它翻译成叫什么呢
叫能量守恒
然后我个人是觉得这个翻译其实是有问题的
应该叫能量保守
为什么呢
因为能量是不守恒的
它的光射到我的表面的时候
肯定是有被我这个表面会吸收的
所以你要损失能量的
但是呢你要确保是说
你从一个球形的空间射进来
所有的能量
最后我以一个球形的把你弹回去之后
我出去的能量一定要小于对吧
到等于或小于你的入射能量
所以我的能量是损失了
我要保守一点对吧
所以他不守恒
所以我觉得翻译成能量守恒的话
这个我个人觉得还是有点误导的
反正我当年学B2DF的时候
我就学着
我就很懵
我说能量怎么守恒呢对吧
能量守恒的话
那我那个参数乱调
他岂不是就不对了嘛对吧
所以说话这个地方的话呢
就是说它的能量就是不能够爆款
那个就是那个唉呀
我也被带偏了
就是它的能量不能保守的话
它在retracing的这种环境下就会出问题
那么第二个问题呢
也是这个这个这个artist的深恶痛绝的问题
就说不定风非常的简单
但是呢他并跟真实的世界的东西啊
关系没有那么大
当你去表达越来越复杂的材质的时候
你会发现bling phone它表达不了那种细节
比如说像左边那个图
那么你靠左边的这个小图的话呢
就是用bling phone做的这个模型
你无论怎么调
你就柏林风有个特点
就是你做什么看上去都很塑料对吧
就是你做那个木头
石头做着像塑料
金属做的也像塑料
就是很很有意思
非常有意思
那么但是的话呢你看现代材质
比如说后面我们会提到的pp r材质的话
它就能非常好的把金属的非金属的对吧
塑料的这个那个这些材质表达得非常到位
所以说我们在现代游戏里面
基本上看到的材质已经不是不灵风了
但是呢这毫无这个这个毫不影响
柏林峰在我们这个渲染上面
很经典的这样一个地位
那么最后一个呢就是讲这个visibility to light
那么shadow呢其实很简单
就是说它实际上呢就是说指我在我眼睛看到的
这个场景里面的每一个点
它道光是不是可见它其实解决的就这一个问题
这个问题当然这个假设是那个光
要么是方向光
要么是点光或者是spotlight
而不是更复杂的光啊
如果是更复杂的光的话呢
它实际上是有一个百分比的
那么其实在这里面啊
就是回顾图形学的早期
大概在二三十年前
其实很早很早的时候
大家就提出了很多的shadow的算法
那么我印象特别深的叫shut volume
大家如果去看那个早期的什么quick啊
还有那个我记得好像quick那个时代用的shadow
好像就是shadow
因为那时候硬件不支持shadow map这些东西
然后包括就是呃还有一些perspective shadow这种方法
就是就是真的是百花齐放
如果你们去search grx的文章
就是特别有意思
就是你看大概呃15年前
20年前的那组paper的话
基本上都是各种各样的方法
但是其实呢在游戏引擎行业
我们呢还是很坚定的
我们说我们只信shadow map
所以游戏行业在过去的整整十几年的
20年里面的话
我们基本上只用了SHMAP这么一个简单算法
但是我现在讲的是他是foundation
就SHUTMP的思想其实非常的straight forward啊
也不叫非常smart
我觉得很聪明
他说你不就是想知道道光的这个这个
这个可见性吗
那我从光的视角渲染一张你的场景
这个渲染呢我不需要你告诉我他的什么名啊
这些东西我不需要知道
你只要告诉我它的深度对吧
那这个深度就表示了你到光的点的那个距离
那么好
我当我去做正面的相机位置的渲染的时候
我每一个点我通过反向投影
把你投影到那个光的那个
就是那个光源的那个视角的那个projection那个地方
然后呢我也也可以得到一个距离
如果我这个距离大于那个就是那个最近的那个
遮挡物的距离的话
那我知道我就在shadow中了
如果我等于或者小于的话
那我就不在shadow中了
这个方法其实是非常的简单
那么具体的更更多的算法细节呢
我觉得在这个课程我就不展开了
如果同学们想了解的话
可以看看那个也令奇的那个101那个课程
他讲的更细
讲的非常的好
我我发现了令奇的课讲得特别的细
把每个算法讲得都很清楚
所以给我这边省了很多事
就是所以呢我这边的话就跟大家讲一下shadow map
最基本的思想
那shadow map其实问题有没有
那当然有了对吧
就是首先最最简单的一个问题
就是说其实你在渲染
从这个光源那边形成的一个shadow map的话
它的采样率我们叫sampling rate
和你从相机这边去看过去的那个世界的采样
它两个采样率是不一样的
如果大家学过信号和系统
就知道
就是说如果采用率是不一样的话
他们就一定会产生各种各样的artifact
那这里面的话就是这个就是shining map的话
最头疼的问题就是说哎自遮挡的问题对吧
特别是那种很精细的结构
如果sha map的精度不够的话
或者说你采样率不够
或者是他那个depth的那个精度不够的话
就会产生很多artifact
那这个课这个事情的话呢
我们游戏行业里我们都是hack大佬
我们怎么办
最简单吧
加个boss就解决了
就是哎我就把它的容差变得更大一点
但是呢你这样会出什么问题呢
就是那个非常简单的就是人脚是浮空的问题
所以大家如果看一些早期的
做的不是特别好的游戏的话
你会发现那个人的阴影离地总是隔个
那么比如说五公分
十公分
这就是很常见的一件事情
那么这件事情的话呢
其实在shadow里面
我给你讲一个故事
就是到直到今天吧
如果用SHADO爸妈的技术
如果当光源特别特别靠近地平线的时候
那个时候shadow都是最难做的
为什么呢
因为那个shadow会拉的非常非常的长
但是呢你知道我们在真实的做游戏的时候
你如果去问艺术家说
你想怎么设计一个场景的时候
艺术家很多时候都想做那种叫夕阳残血的效果
说诶同学们
我想表达一个环境对吧
血红的夕阳下
然后那个那个天空出现了五彩的云
然后呢这个建筑拖了长长的影子
然后一个人只能看到他的剪影
当艺术家开始这样描述的时候
一般graphics engineer那时候就开始抓头了
就说我我的天呐
大哥你这是要整死我的杰作
我给大家讲一下
就是现在的游戏
游戏的话
我忘了是什么游戏的
是最新的一个很不错的很不错的一个游戏
他那个当时是说我做了两套shadow算法
当那个那个阳光基本上还是比较
靠近天顶的时候对吧
比如说在傍晚之前
我用了算法A当你开始逐渐逐渐接近地平线了
比如说清晨和傍晚的时候
诶
我慢慢的传C生成另外一套算法
才能解决这个问题
所以说我具体echo一下
就是那个graphics大佬说的话
就是shadow
真的就是我们做graphics
程序员最头疼的一个问题
所以抱怨不会抱怨
但是这个是我们的革命的老伙伴
所以其实啊这样一个非常简单的solution对吧
我用一个简单光源加上AMINOL
然后呢用environment map去hack一下
这个你的快速的反射
然后呢
我把你的这个render equation的光的那部分
给你hack掉了
然后呢我用bling phone对吧
把你的这个这个这个卷积的问题
也变得非常的简单了
我也不算那么多东西了
我就直接给你几个几个
就是其实是POLNOL
就是这个多项式的这种计算的时间
我就能算出你的光照了
然后呢唉我再加上一个shadow map对吧
一个简单的就是在光源空间去采个样
我就能大概骇客出来
我到光到底是不是可见
我把你的三个挑战基本上全解决了
其实啊就这么一个东西
它最后形成的结果如果配上很好的艺术家的
出的效果并不差
这边的话是动画的画面吗
就是我个人觉得就是说你不仔细看
你觉得诶这个画面还可以
至少不影响我去享受这个剧情了
所以这个呢我我我在写到这一趴的时候啊
突然就诗兴大发了
就是我突然想起来了
我们中国特别可爱的五九改对吧
就是远抗
因为我是一个那个这个名民科
加上一个这个伪军迷
所以我就远看五对负负重人
就是你那个五九改
五九在最中间那个地方
但是我们见过40年对他各种魔改
其实啊这些我刚才讲的那个三件套的那个
那个方法呀
实际上即使到今天在有些特殊的场合
他还是挺管用的
比如说在一些啊游戏超低配的时候
诶我就全部切到这个非常简单的方法去做了
包括一些如果硬件的技能不是特别好的时候
比如在移动端的时候
我其实也可以这么做
所以呢而且呢大家在理解渲染的时候
这个呢是大家最基础的理解渲染的东西
所以这个老伙伴我的建议是大家一定要先学
先掌握它
然后呢我们在进入我们真正的高端的部分
这也是所以接下来的课程的话
就会相对来讲比较高能了
那这个东西
这个这个东西是怎么就是是怎么产生的呢
首先得说一下
这个很著名的就是3A游戏行业对吧
我看国内很多游戏开发者天天说我们要做3A
我们做3A是3A
这个行业还是蛮有意思的
就是我觉得3A这个行业最大的特点是什么呢
就是自己给自己找麻烦
因为我以前在美国做游戏的时候
我还是蛮能感受到那种文化
就是说每天早上醒来会问自己
就是说我怎么样能够给自己搞一些
更挑战的问题
就好好的日子
不过就是既然你的三件套那么好使
那我为什么要给你们做的一样的对吧
我既然自称我是个3A的人对吧
我就要高人一等
那我就得这个做的跟你们就不一样
对这其实就是这样一份执着对吧
其实本质上就是想把大家钱包里的钱
全部掏出来
那作为3A同学们
我们的这个这个行业的工程师们
就每天早上起来就想说
我一定要做的跟大家不一样
其实呢这个行业呢
我个人觉得它的一个最大的突飞猛进
其实从15年前开始吧
就是特别是在2003年04年
学着这个SHADER
就是可编程硬件的出发
其实你会发现就是商业行业的游戏的品质
和一般的游戏差距就会拉的很大
对不对
那么这个是那个刺客信条
15年前的画面
老师低低座的刺客信条
那可是我第一次热爱上
怎么就跳草堆了
这个草跳草堆这种事情
我居然会非常喜欢
而且觉得哇那个站在那个顶上看世界
简直是一种享受
但实际上呢我把这个图截下来之后
我一看哎呀好像画面哎也就那么一般般了对吧
好像那个资料还有点僵
那么其实呢在这个过去的10年里面
我们还是以刺客信条为例啊
你会发现他的画面真的是越做越好
越做越好
你比如像5年前这一作起源对吧
那你看到他就做了很多在精彩里面探秘啊
各种内部的光照
看着你就就就是说这个如梦如幻
但是呢最新的像大革命啊
像这些那个那个娃哈娜
这个就越做越好了
那今天我不展开
因为我今天这一趴讲的是什么呢
是这个上一个时代的3A游戏做的效果
注意啊
我讲的不是最新的
最新的
我最后回去点一下
因为那个太复杂了
那我先讲一下
就是呃大家印象中的
比如说五到10年前这个行业
这10年里面我们所研发的这个技术
那么这个还是按刚才那个思路来讲
就是说首先我们要解决的问题是什么呢
还是光照的问题好
这光照问题很难对吧
就是这个球面的光怎么办
这个其实我我我
我把它简化成一个暧昧的一个常数
这个实在是太不礼貌了
这个卡基亚老先生知道了肯定会很生气的
对不对
虽然他扣不了我的工资
那我们就想到了一个办法
说唉算了
我预计算好不好
就是我把这些
我反正假设场景中90%的东西
它都是不动的
假设太阳的角度
我每个关卡我就锁死了对吧
那我是不是可以通过预计计算
这就是计算机那个图形学里
或者计算机引擎里面
最常用的一个思路叫什么呢
我相信大家以前学过那个数据结构的
知道有个说法叫什么叫空间换时间对吧
大家记记不记得
其实这个就是一个非常典型的
空间换时间的思路
就是我用PRECOMPUTER
我来去看看能不能把这个这个这里面哦
不好意思
有一个词儿我还突然冒出来叫global nination
这个词
听上去非常的高大上
全局光照对吧
我相信现在很多同学买游戏的时候都会问
这个游戏支不支持全局光照啊
对不对
全局光照on and off会有什么效果呀
它本质上就是说哎我的这个光啊
就是比如说来自四面八方反射的光对吧
就是如果想能分解一点
就是直接光照和间接光照叫inja light都有的
这种光照叫全局光照
那我们呢把这个所有的这种光的效果
全部预计算出来
那怎么办
就是那首先的话呢我们要解释一下
就是说为什么全局光照这件事情这么重要
那这里面就是左边和右边这个图
就是在游戏中啊
我们有大量的场景
他其实比如说你坐在一个房间里面对吧
那如果比如白天家里是不开灯的
对不对
那你这个如果只算直接光照的话
你看到的是什么呢
你看到的就是这个像我这个图
这个左边的这个样子对吧
那好那我们怎么high
我可以high啊
我可以加个N倍的
但是MING的加上去
它的一个特点是什么呢
就是你家里面所有东西都统一变量了
看上去非常具有平面感
如果大家回想一下
你们以前玩的这种20年前的游戏的话
15年前的游戏吧
你进到室内的时候
特别是一些网游
你会发现感觉这个里面的房间特别的平面
就是你几乎感受不到什么光照
这个原因呢
其实不是因为那个就是程序员不努力
是因为他真的没有做全局光照
因为你要做全局光照的话
你才能模拟出来这种诶光照到地上对吧
地上反弹回来
又把房间的天花板和墙应亮了
这样你走的人的话
他才有种光的感觉
所以全局光照啊
其实对于这种真实感的刻画
实际上是非常非常重要的一件事情
那这个时候我们的挑战是什么呢
就是这个全职光照拿到之后啊
它实际上是一个在球面空间的一个采样对吧
你可以把一个球像地图一样展开这个map
那么但是我如果存了这种东西的话
它的数据量会不会非常的大对吧
如果我整个场景只踩一个没问题
我服了对吧
那我也能存好
就算你能把整个场景的这个光照全部踩下来
你这个时候你我给你一个材质
你说我这一个DE图片和整个这个材质上的
球面光照怎么去算
他的这个这个就是积分呢
啊这这又是要命的一个事情
对不对
那你当然了
你可以用最粗暴的
比如蒙特卡罗的方法
就是我就是在这个球上撒无数个采样点
比如撒100个好
我每一个每一个方向都给你算一下
算一下
我再积分一下
但是大家想想看
我们在做绘制的时候
每一个这个屏幕上你看到像素
我要去做它的shading的时候
我都要跟这个这个这个球状的
这个整个光照函数的积分一下啊
都都都做一下采样
然后再做一个累加对吧
其实这个卷积运算了
那是不是这个要疯掉了对吧
那这个所以的话呢我们需要去想一种方法
能让这个积分非常快速的能够进行
这其实就是摆在我面前的挑战
这个时候呢我就要哎对这个地方开始高能了
但但这个地方
如果大家上过那个101202的课程
这个地方我们我觉得我们俩课程真的要联动了
我这两天一直在跟林奇在聊
我说你简直救了我的命
我发现你很多东西你的课程已经讲的非常好了
我直接就框包括这张图
这个图我是直接从他的那个啊课程里面
直接抠出来了
我觉得他讲的特别好
因为本质上啊回到上野啊
就是不好意思
回到上一
回到上一页那个这个球面上
它是一个无穷为的
这个这个这个信号它是个连续信号对吧
你你只能在它进行采样表达
它实际上是无限的向量
那这时候你碰到这种信号的时候
你怎么办
那我不得不说我们的傅里叶的这个老先生
这是啊1830年去世的一个数学家
我现在真的想不明白
就是他在那个时代
为什么搞了这么一套特别牛逼的傅里叶变换
这样能够把各种循环的这个信号
它能够把它分解成几个不同的这种频率的信号
的一个累加
我真的想不出这个应用
但是我我我今天还特别饶有兴致地
做了一件很无聊的事情
就是我查了一下麦克斯韦
老先生是哪一年出生的
我发现是麦克斯韦是啊
他是1930年死的
麦克斯韦是1931年出生的
也就是说他死后一年后
麦克斯韦才出生了对吧
因为你到无线电的时候
比如说我我无线电的信号来的时候
我是调频啊
截屏啊
我需要这套技术
但是我不知道数学家为什么那么牛逼
有先见之明
把这套数学工具就给出来了
但是呢这个分裂变换听上去非常的高大上啊
但是其实它非常的非常的有用
就是说比如说我在空间上的一个信号
这张图也是从另起的这个课件上透出来的
我觉得特别好使
就是你给我一张照片
我可以把它分析成一个
傅里叶变换的一个频率谱
就是把这个从空间域变成频域
这个时候呢
如果我在频域中只截取前面的一小段
实际上我就完成了对你的信号的一个
非常粗糙的表达
但这个表达虽然会粗糙
但是呢基本上能让我看出来这是什么东西
比如像这里面他只取了九项
你就能看到这个小女孩的大致的样子
这件事情是不是很神奇
对不对
本来我要存一个完整的照片
到这边我就诶就可以拿到这个小姑娘的照片
这个就是怎么说呢
在我知道福利变换之前的话
如果有人让我写这个效果
我只能用最简单的就是加权平均
加权平均吧
土的要死诶
但是你一旦上到了这个傅里叶变换之后
你发现他的一切就有数学的这个解释了
所以正是因为这个方式它其实有很多好处
第一个好处呢
就是你本来像这个小女神的照片对吧
他是呃差不多
我看了一下大概200×200的像素对吧
1万45万的数据
但是呢他可能用九个参数就能够大概表达出来
这个小姑娘长长什么样子对吧
但是我不知道这个数据是不是真的久
也许要更多一点
但反正anyway你确实是可以压缩
高速高效的压缩这个数据的
第二个好处是什么呢
就是当你啊对这个图像和另外一个图像
做任何的叫积分运算
或者讲的
其实大家如果学深度深度学习的话
有一个词用的特别多
也是我这边的这个标题叫做卷积
就是对它进行这种卷积运算的时候
你会发现你不需要那么傻傻的
对这几万个数据点进行一次的
这个叫乘法加累加运算
那会算是你的诶
你只要把它投入到频域空间的那几个参数
进行一次卷积就可以就可以得到它的结果
这是一个非常厉害的牛逼的一个数学性质
所以当大家把这个性质提出来之后
接下来就来了一个大名鼎鼎的
这个球面调和函数叫sofa harmonix
这个SUVHARMONIX是真的是非常了不起
就是我当年学到这一趴的时候
我真的是惊为天人
你知道吗
而且呃我特别崇拜
就特别佩服
就是把这个数学工具
引到我们graphics领域里来的这个人
这个老哥呢如果我没记错啊
叫peter pex lo
叫皮皮斯隆
我们叫他皮斯隆
这个老哥我是特别讨厌跟他一起开会的
为什么呢
他是个北欧人
身高大概有1米9几
快接近2米了
每次我跟他开会的时候
我就这样看着他就特别有压迫感
你知道吗
就是所以我跟大家讲
就是你跟老外开会的时候
最好自己个子高一点
如果你的个子像我这样只是在中国叫中等的话
你很多时候尽量远离北欧的那些科学家
因为他的专业上给你强不强不重要
首先从气势上
他就把你碾压到了
那么皮特帕克斯龙同志呢
他真的是非常了不起
他那时候还在微软
在direct team
他就想到说诶
他当时就提出来那个叫PRT对吧
然后呢他就是pre computer
什么那个什么什么reader transfer吧
那个全称叫什么来着
我已经有点忘了
然后呢他就说他想到了这个基函数
这个方harmonics啊
它其实它是一组sin和sin的一个函数集
你听上去非常的复杂
但其实啊它的数学性质是非常非常简单的
那么你看到了
比如说一阶的这个函数
它就是一个加权平均嘛
在球面上所有的型号加权平均二阶函数呢
你其实可以想象成在球面上的每一个方向
那么大家想想啊
如果是个球坐标记坐标
你有CTF两个角度对吧
决定了一个方向
那么如果你在笛卡尔坐标系里面
你去表达它的时候
是不是就变成了一个归一化的一个向量
XYZ啊
虽然它有三个值
但是就是X平方加Y平方
加Z平方一定要等于一
对不对
所以它其实只有两个自由度的
那么实际上它的第一阶的那个三个基函数呢
就是Y值ZHX值简不简单对吧
当你在X轴的正面正面的时候
那个值就是X对吧
在X轴的负的时候就是负负负负负的这个值
那么ZY也是一样的
那么即使到了第二节的时候
他其实也不复杂
你会发现就是说他每一次上一节
他的多项式就多上了一一阶而已
但是呢它的外形看上去就特别的魔幻
这个图的话大家看一下
就是呃绿色表示是正直
红色表示负值
你发现没有
就是说实际上它在这个空间上
是不是就是在一阶的时候
像两头鼓出去的一个泡泡
这个形状其实非常的漂亮
然后呢到二阶的时候就变得更加精彩了
三阶四阶越来越好看了
这里面很神奇啊
就是他的这些所有的这些无限维的这些函数啊
它们都是什么的
都是正交的
正交的什么意思
就是说你把它们卷积在一起
它的值永远是零
这个非常有意思
那么这个东西呢实际上真的是
我觉得我我自己一直觉得
上这个这个世界的技术原理
到底是物理的还是数学的
我觉得大概率可能是数学的吧
如果氢原子里面的那个电子轨道
跟这个东西几乎是一模一样
我这边还今天还特别的这个这个
这个闲得蛋疼的
就是去找了我们同学说
哎同学们查一下氢原子的电子轨
我记得以前我在学习for harmonix的时候
好像老师跟我讲过这个事儿
我们又查了一遍
发现诶好像是对的
真的是这样子的
所以说这个harmonic函数也是非常了不起
就是在这个讲的数学上更更深一点
更有意思的一个属性
就是说它的二阶导永远是零
什么意思呢
就表示它这个函数永远是光滑的
它的变化永远是非常的流畅和光滑
你看多么的和谐
就这么一个简单的函数
它就解决了我们所有的问题
那这样的话
当我来到了一个球面的光照信号的时候
你就可以用非常简单的一个POLNOL的
就是这个一个多项式的一个
其实连多项式的就是一阶多项式
一个乘法加加法
你就可以把这个信号大致地表达出来
那这里面的话
你看到下面有几个非常复杂的信号吗
实际上你用几阶的这个就是SAFARMONIX
就能近似的表达表达出来
当然了
在我们的游戏中的话
我们一般不会用的那么复杂
我们一般用到像最早我记得在做halo的时候
我们用到了好像是二阶还是三阶吧
但是的话其实现在很多时候
大家只用到一阶就完事了
为什么呢
因为我只需要表达低频
这里面给大家举个例子啊
比如说当我有了这样的一个工具的时候
我在这个场景里面
我在任何一个点
我这时候看到的东西是什么呢
诶是一个是一个light probe对吧
就是或者叫erence prom进来的光
那我把这个球呢
假设按地图一样的展开成
一个一个一个一个地图
就像这边屏幕的右下角
出现在那个小长条形方块
我用SAFHONEX对它进行压缩
这里面呢我们只取它的这个
就是说呃S0和S1总共只有四个参数
那大家看看我重建出来的这个图
是不是虽然看上去非常的糊
但是呢它基本上能告诉听说光从哪边来对吧
哪个比较黑
哪边比较亮
这件
而且它的整个过整个数据是非常连续的
而且如果我要去问
在任何一个方向的光强到底是多少的话
只要用一次线性的就是vector运算就完成了
这张图呢
我是选自于2018年的戴斯的一个报告
他讲行双引擎里面他用的这个技术
那么其实他就说这个其实够了
为什么呢
如果我用它去做一些就是表达环境光
因为环境光大家会发现啊
如果我把主光给抠掉之后啊
环境光很多时候它就是低频的
所以这样压缩它的效果其实基本够用了
而且这样的话呢
它就有一个非常有意思的属性了
就是我去表达一个点上的
它整个一个球状的光的话
你会发现它只需要14个12个参数
那为什么是12个参数呢
刚才我们讲了四个参数嘛对吧
那为什么这个时候变成12个呢
其实因为它的颜色是有颜色的
就是说我要去压缩一下诶
蓝色的在这个层面上的分布
我要说要绿色对吧
红色RGB3个颜色
所以呢就是4×32个参数
这里面的话呢就要讲个细节
这个细节我觉得觉得我觉得他讲的非常的好
这里面我也分享给同学们分享一下
就是说它虽然有四个参数啊
但这四个参数权重是不一样的
比如说你的一阶L0
就是说那个那个均匀的球的第一个第零阶函数
它不是相当于对我整个环境的广场
做了一次加权平均吗
那这个时候呢因为我们现代游戏基本上是HDR的
所以呢它对它的压缩采取了HDR的压缩方法
它这里面选择了就是那个BC6H
这个H可能就代表这个high resolution的这样
一个东西对它
但是它只是一个阿尔法channel的去压缩
但是的话呢他对于他的那个剩下的两个接的话
他用的都是这个LDR的压缩方法
那实际上就算他用高精度的
比如说这个b c seven去压缩它的话
那实际上它的一个球面上的
整个一个光照的表达
他只用了多少呢
只用了大概24个beat
这个事情其实非常的了不起啊啊啊啊
这个啊32个beat
这32beat是什么概念呢
就是我们在游戏里面存一个颜色
假设只有这个一就是一个BT
表示一个测的就是256个色阶吧
都不是HDR颜色
我存一个RGBA就是32个那个by a beat
所以这意味着什么
就是我用了一个存在阿尔法的颜色的空间
就能存一个在每个点上的一个光照
所以这件事情是非常了不起的
他那么他带过来第二个很大的好处呢
这里面我今天不展开了
就是说我因为把这个光用SAFARMAX去表达
那我去算diffuse
甚至我在算SPEARKER的时候呃
其实在那个death的文章中
他只算了diffuse
实际上在最早halo3的这个工作中的话呢
我们把SPARKER也做
因为hero3当时对这个SAFARMA存在接触比较高
好像我记得存到了二阶或者三阶了
那么实际上你都可以把它转换成
两个向量之间的点击或者是卷积就完事儿了
非常的简单
大家有如果有兴趣的话
可以去推导一下这个
这个反正就是如果大家没有兴趣没关系
直接在网上找公司
你就按这个去写
一般来讲不会错
但是注意有些有些有些parameter要归化对吧
经常你有时候忘了除一个派
这个就这个整个数值就完全不一样了
所以呢但是呢他的思想他就告诉你说
我在球面上两个函数的卷积可以简化成
你把两个函数分别投影到
SURFHONICS的这个机上去
你投影出来的参数
这两个参数之间的卷积就等于他们的结果
这个事情其实非常的了不起
所以有了这么神奇的这个数学工具之后
我们就可以做一件非常丧心病狂的事情了
就是大名鼎鼎的LIGHTMAP
那这里面我要跟大家澄清概念
就light map这个词啊
不叫光照贴图吗
实际上不是为了做全局光照发明出来最早light map
如果我没记错的话
应该是在还是我们那个大神吧
KMARK在做最早的quick时代
好像他那个shadow算不过来
他好像就已经用了light map
预先的把这个这个shadow就算好了
但是呢后来随着shadow的技术
比如说shadow map这些技术的发展
大家就觉得哇塞真是太土了
我们就不这么干了
但是呢等我突然发现
我们需要算全局光照的时候
诶
这个老祖宗的利器又被寄出来了
我们发现我们应该用light map的思想
就是把整个场景的这个光照
给烘培到一张图上去
因为我有我有很了不起的数学工具
叫SAFARMONIX嘛
所以说你会发现
就是基于全局光照的LUMAP技术啊
是在peter park sloan
好像是提出了PPT之后才爆发出来了
如果我没记错的话
好像halo是第一家做这个东西的人
那么当然这个这个有待查实啊
因为我现在没有那么多的时间
在做其他的research工作
但是呢基本上是这个思想
允许我们去做这样一件事情了
那么这边的话
你看的就是那烘烘烘烘焙出来的贴图
那个图我们一般叫什么呢
叫做atlas
atlas呢
翻译成中文叫做航海图或者地图
就是你就是把很多的几何拍到一张图上去
我们叫做atlas
那怎么个拍法呢
首先呢你要对这个世界进行几何的简化
就是你不能用那个非常fine的那个geometry
就非常清晰的结合geometry
因为什么呢
因为这里面有一个有一部
有一部课程叫PRIMARIZATION
就是说把三维空间的复杂的几何
把它投影到二维的空间
如果你是一个比如说一个方块或者是一个球
这个promotion呢就是参数化呢是比较简单的
但是大家想象一个任意的形状对吧
无数个三角形
它的参数化是比较复杂的
所以呢我们会对这个几何进行简化
然后呢我们要进行这个在参数空间进行分配
这里面有个小小的细节
就是我们尽可能希望
在同样的这个面积或者体积里面
我分给你的这个texture resolution
就是那个那个那个就是texture的那个精度
基本是类似的
这东西听上去很抽象
但是我觉得这张图讲的特别好
就是如果我把每一个text标成不同的颜色
但就是大家现在看到的格子吗
你发现他反向投影回这个世界上
你看诶好像每个格子大小都比较均匀
这件事情啊是一个LIGHTMAP很重要的一个需求
但是呢真正大家在数学上写一写
还不是那么简单的
我如果没记错的话
direct大概在呃十几年前专门开发了一个API
就帮助你做这个参数化展开的那个这件事情
那个东西的话其实啊很重要非常重要
但是我们当时一直在用
一边用一边抱怨
他的好像有很多小问题
不知道现在修的怎么样了
然后呢这个时候我其实开始给他做lighting了
这个lighting呢
实际上这个讲解来就比较丧心病狂了
就是这个lighting
实际上我们有一个巨大无比的叫light farm
这个farm呢是有很多台很快的电脑
这个做成的一个集群
然后呢这个当美术做完了场景之后
把光源设置好
参数设置好点
一个叫烘培
我们叫做那个叫我记得以前叫baking点一下好
这个时候美术可以干什么事情呢
美术就可以出去买一杯星巴克了
然后呢可以坐在阳台上跟同学们一边抽着烟
一边喝着星巴克
一般来讲会半个小时到一个小时左右
所以我记得那个时候
当我们用LIGHTMAP这个技术的时候
呃
我实际上就很痛恨这个技术
我觉得我的天呐
这个会让我们3A游戏开发的效率急剧下降
所以当我后来自己做引擎的时候
我就坚决不肯上light ma
宁死不从对吧
但实际上的话那效果上肯定会打折扣的
因为light烘出来的效果确实是很好看的
那么它可以烘出非常漂亮的这种这种来
这个就是全局光照的效果
然后呢你再把它附上这种就是直接光照在一起
你会发现这两张图的比较
就是这个是啊只有LIGHTMAP的图
你会发现很多光在里面bouncing的效果都会有了
而且你能看到就是两个临近的很近的建筑物之
间的物体之间的这种软阴影
但是呢你这个时候再加上domino lighting
就是主光源的时候
整个这个光这个环境就非常的饱满
然后你再配合上材质
你会发现这个感觉就非常的真实
如果这个关卡的话
就这个这个场景的话
如果没有LIGHTMAP的那个就是那个补充那个GI的
就是全局光的东西的话
它看上去会非常的难看
为什么呢
因为你看你会发现它的光只能照进场景的
很小的一块
而且呢你就算用安静的去补的话
其实那些不能被光照到的结构
它的名啊
它的几何关系你是看不出来的
所以说这个GI就是global emission的感觉
对三游戏来讲的话是非常重要的一个一个属性
那么所以LIGHTMAP的话呢
这个技术的话呢
我这里面不会展开特别的细啊
但是希望同学们就是分享一下我自己的理解
它的好处是什么呢
就是说你别看它烘培速度特别慢
但是呢它在实时的时候
RUA的时候其实效率非常的高
因为它成本非常非常的低
那么第二个的话呢
就是说它因为它是离线baking的嘛
他把整个空间这个分分解之低下之后
它可以产生很多很细节的
很subtle的这种效果
这种效果的话说实话艺术家是非常喜欢的对吧
就像这里面那个飞船
它在地上那种软软的那种就是明暗关系
会让你一下子觉得这个东西跃然于纸上的感觉
那么它的缺点呢
刚才也讲了
第一个就是非常长的这个预计算时间
包括今天我在准备这个课程的时候
我没有办法去给大家一个完整的来看我的图
为什么呢
因为我们的引擎没有
然后在网上搜也没搜到
因为我当时我做引擎的时候
我就特别不想做这个玩意儿
我觉得这个东西实在是太麻烦了对吧
那么你要构建一个lion f
然后呢
第二个呢
就是说它只能处理静态的物体和静态的光
大家想想是不是就是当你的这个物体一旦变了
或者光源一旦动了
你以前烘焙的东西就全部完蛋了
当然有些同学也很丧心病狂的
想做那种可以real time更新的light map
但是在工业界呢我见到的好像比较少
就比较难
其实确实很难
但是呢动态物体其实是有办法hack的
就是以前比如说在做一些简单的游戏的时候
我们可以说哎
我从这个物体从周围去sampling一个点赞的LIGHTMAP
我就能获得猜到黄金光长什么样子
这时候我给他一个光照
那么但是呢这个效果其实有很多的问题呢
就比如说以前最经典的一个bug是什么
就是地上LIGHTMAP投入了一个shadow
你这个人走上去的时候
这个人那么大
一个小小的shadow
把人突然一下子变黑了
你人在走开的时候
哎这个人又变亮了对吧
这个效果就非常的这个非常的塑料
非常有问题
那么这其实也是LIGHTMAP一个很大的一个挑战
那么第三个挑战呢就是我想了
既然咱们是一个叫空间换时间的策略嘛
那在run time的时候
LIGHTMAP本身占用个几百啊
几十兆到几百兆的存储空间是很常见
一般来讲是几十兆到100兆左右吧
这取决于你的场景有多大
但是呢就场景大了之后
它导致的问题还烘焙时间也足够长
这个方法呢就是实际上我在后面会讲的
就是现代游戏中啊
我个人认为啊
light map的方法可能会逐渐被淘汰掉了
但是呢为什么我是特别喜欢
特别希望跟大家去讲一下
这个light map的这个方法呢
因为他的有两个思想
其实我个人觉得是非常了不起的
第一个思想呢就是说啊空间换时间对吧
我用存储空间把大量的一句算放在这
第二个思想呢叫我对整个游戏的场景
把它参数化到一个比如说二维的texture上去对吧
其实我也可以把它参数化成一个
三维的WORKO上去
当我把这个空间啊
就是本来大家理解一下游戏的环境
它是非常复杂的
各种各样的几何面片东西
但是我一旦把它变成一个非常容易管理
非常容易表达的这样的一个2D的texture
或者是3D的一个涡轮的话
其实我很多的计算就可以去做了
所以这个思想的话呢
我希望同学们能够get到
所以说我们今天这个104的课程
我一般会跟大家讲
就说我不会特别纠结于每个算法的
具体的时间的细节
但是呢我是特别希望和同学们分享一下
就是说当你遇到一个
因为今天我讲的所有的算法
可能并不能解决你未来真的在做引擎
真的在做游戏
你所遇到的困难
但是你一旦掌握了这种方法之后
其实你可以发明你自己的新的算法
所以这就是like map
OK好
那接下来的话呢
就是其实也是非常straightforward的一个想法了
那你既然把空间上去
把这个把这么复杂的这种几何给我拍平了对吧
太麻烦了
对不对
大家如果有人写过那个就是参数化的算法的话
你就知道那绝对是恶心的不得了
写写不好就一堆bug
我来个更简单粗暴的
我在空间上撒一堆的这个采样点对吧
我们叫什么叫light prop
你不是说每一个点上的那个光照
就是一个一个一个一个半球嘛对吧
那就是个泡芙嘛
好我就放一堆light pop对吧
你看这张图中就是这个图
不一定大家能看得清楚啊
你可以看到那个字
如果仔细看你会发现那个这是一个这是FA
就是那个啊就是微软的当家花旦的赛车游戏
这是当年我最爱玩的一个赛车游戏之一吧
我我这个这个我还是蛮喜欢这个游戏的
然后呢是force最新的一座horizon
他就用了这个light prop的这个技术
他就讲解说
你看我在平面
我在这个赛道上撒了无数的这个light probe对吧
然后呢我对于每个prop诶
我采样它的整个广场
当这个你们任何一个物体或者人
在你们去移动的时候
诶
我就去找我周边的这些那个light probe
对它进行一个差值
就算出我的光照
它旁边那个小动画
大家自己看那个小球的颜色一直在变
为什么呢
因为它当它在动的时候
它的邻居一直在变
这里面的话就是一个很简单的空间体系化的
这么一个算法
就是我要把这些light problem变成一个个的点
然后呢我连出很多的叫四面体对吧
Trohr
然后呢我就可以对它进行插值了
这个算法其实啊如果大家稍微学一学
难度并不大
那么我就可以采样
其实light pp呢有一个很有意思的问题
就是哪个老哥去把这些点摆上去
在早期的live power
比如早期我们做一些规模比较小的游戏
的时候呢
我们喊粗暴说对吧
我记得以前我我我我我跟ARTI思想说
你不是想要pp吗
来我给你做个工具
你自己点吧
对artist说好
我要这个效果
我也我愿意点对吧
但是呢其实到后面他就发现这事他不想干
为什么呢
因为level artist他经常会改这个关卡的设置对吧
我今天放了这个点
我沿着这个通道很精彩
因为你不能乱点
你尽量沿着这个玩家走的通道去放嘛
对不对
那好那每一次你关卡一旦变了之后
你得再重新改
而且这个地方经常会改错
而且会有无数的bug圆缺
所以呢我看了一下
就现代的游戏呢
很多时候它是有自动化生成的方法了
那简单来讲的话
就是我对空间的几何进行
我首先均匀的产生采样点
然后呢根据玩家的可大大区域
包括建筑物的这个几何往外往外做一个延拓
我然后呢相对均匀的去把这个点撒出去
这个算法其实并不难
但是呢就是说这个呢
我认为说如果今天同学们做light pro算法的时候
假设是真的工业级应用的
我会建议就是大家想办法
就是写一个这个这个light pop自动生成的算法
因为这样的话你会发现
当你进入到真正的就是这个生产流程的时候
艺术家会爱死你
那如果你让他手动点的话哦
他肯定会恨很恨你的
你要小心点
嗯所以这是垃圾pop怎么去生成
那你这里面再讲另外一个很有意思的概念
就是说其实light pp呢我们去采样的时候呢
一般会踩的比较密
但是呢我们可能会用一些压缩算法
比如说把精度压的非常的低
因为我主要用它做光照模
讲的就是光照
如果做diffuse的话
其实可以非常的低频
就这个地方如果我有算法和max压缩
也没什么太大问题
但是呢我们在游戏里面有很多非常光亮
不灵不灵的东西
对不对
那你这个人走在这个环境里面
他身上反射的东西是不是要经常会变呢
所以呢我们会有的时候会专门做一种prop
叫做reflection probe
就是说反射pro它的特点是什么呢
首先呢我做的不会特别多
但是呢它做的它采样的精度很高
为什么呢
因为那个反射它对高频是非常敏感的
所以我希望能看到大概清楚周围的环境
这个里面的话呢
一般来讲它会分开的
和这个就是啊
就是那个光照的那个problem去采样
它的密度会低
但是呢它的精度会高
所以基本上你把这两个东西放在一起的话
你就能够实现一个诶还挺不错的一个GI的效果
它的好处是什么呢
就是第一个RUA其实也是非常快的对吧
然后呢它能处理就是静态物体和动态物体
而且呢它有个很好的优势是什么呢
就是说你其实啊是可以在RUNTIME的时候
可以更新它的
就是你这个场景如果发生了一些变化
包括人物发生的位置发生的变化
实际上现在计算机上light prop是可以软弹更新的
这个里面呢有一个细节
就是说啊我要去做light pop怎么做呢
大家想想看怎么做
我是不知道是不是在这边放个相机
然后呢朝上看看
朝左看看
朝右看看
把周围拍六张照片
诶我把它拼成一个图
然后这个图拿到之后呢
我再用我快速无比的这个GPU的SHADER
对它进行各种各样的处理
那个速度其实也非常快
那么一般来讲呢我们去做light pop更新呢
它的特点是说我们不会每一帧都去更新
这个prop
就是说我们基本上隔几帧
或者说我会判断你的位置
是不是发生了巨大的变化呀
场景是发生变化了
而且我一旦发生变化的时候
我也不会马上就更新
我可能会找一张比较空的时候去更新
所以这个呢也就是说在现代引擎架构的时候
我们会有一个概念
就是说有一些update我们会differ就不会马上做
否则的话
你会导致你的帧率在那一下子突然就不稳定了
所以的话呢就是说呃就是light probe的一个一个
很很有意思的一个特点
但是呢它的缺点呢就是他比不上light map
因为它能给你里面动的物体
非常好的光照感对吧
环境也有这种感觉
但是呢他没有办法实现
就是像light pap那种
非常nicely的这种soft shadow的感觉啊
这个物体之间那种交叠的感觉
这个感觉真的做不到
包括有一些非常漂亮的那种color的
leading的效果呢
他做的也不是特别的好
这就是因为你的材料太稀疏了嘛
对不对
人家light map对吧
在一个地图上
他要采大概几百万个点
你light problem你再狠几万个也就不得了了
所以你是人家几1%的采样率
你肯定达不到人家这个效果
所以这个世界是很公平的
所以你用这个方法的话
就是说light map加light prop方法
基本上在过去的就业就是说十几年的话
你能够hack出来一个还挺像那个样子的
一个光照的效果
那么好
光的问题我们用这种方法就基本上解决了
接下来我们要解决第二个问题就是材质了
这里面呢就要引入我们大名鼎鼎的这个
基于物理的材质系统来打physics basement based material
pp r对吧
其实应该是physical rendering pdr
那个p r rendering pp r material对吧
他这里面其实概念挺多的
比如说p p r lighting pp r这个camera p p r这个material
但是呢这个都是吓唬人的
我们今天的话呢
这个既然这个数学上或者说行业
你们大家喜欢吓唬人
那我今天就决定这个也也失从一下来
先给大家看一个非常酷的东西
就非常吓唬人的东西
叫微平面理论
这个其实呢大家如果学习过图形学理论课的
同学们都知道我对吧
听上去非常的高大上
但实际上呢是蛮简单的
就是在在这个里面的话呢
我觉得他有一点讲的特别好
就是他他用一套假设解释了就是各种光学现象
他认为就是说一个表面它就是无数的反射
那么如果你假设是一个全是金属表面吧
你看起来粗糙
看起来这个就是说那个他的那个就是光滑
实际上跟他表面法向的聚集度有关
如果他所有的这个小表面的法向都集中在一起
那你看上去就非常的shining对吧
反光很好
如果全是一个方向的话
那就是镜子了
对不对
但如果它分散的比较开
你看上去就比较糊
这个逻辑其实是非常非常简单的一个逻辑
那么这里面的话呢
就引入了一个非常著名的这样的一个一个模型
就是这个这个模型呢
其实现在大家用的最多的是GGX模型
说实话就是我在这个行业待了这么久
到现在为止
我还没搞明白为什么这个模型叫GGX对吧
但是大家到后来发现我们都在用GGS这个模型
这个模型大概是2007年提出来的吧
那个包括我查了原文
他这个文章中突然出现了
叫GGX这三个字的时候
没有任何解释
然后我就一脸懵逼
我说啊怎么回事
那其实呢
它这里面有一个很很有意思的一个解释
这里面的话呢其实讲解的很高大上
但实际上很简单
就是说其实一个光啊打到物体表面
它无非就发生两种事情
第一种事情呢就是我把你的光弹回去了对吧
弹回去呢我能弹多少
取决于我表面的这个法向的这个分母
就是roughness
它的速度
如果它的法向特别散乱
那我们彼此之间的话呢
就会这个这个这个就是发散
就是就是说你可以看到高光很发散
但是呢还有些光它会设计到物体里面
好这里面高能的地方来了
就其实也也不用那么复杂
就是如果是金属对吧
金属的电子可以捕获这些光子
那那些电子呢就把这些光子给笑纳了
对不对
但是呢如果是非金属诶电子
它就没有能力捕获这些这个光子
这个光子就在里面来来回弹几下
然后呢以一个随机的方向射出去了
就相当于一度一束光射到物体表面
在里面发生了几次这个折射之后
啪就全散出去了
这个东西是什么呢
就是diffuse对吧
非常简单
所以呢PB2的材质
它的模型实际上就是两趴
一趴呢就是number version的漫反射的这个部分
这个部分其实非常的简单
就是如果你把球面上所有的这个漫反射的部分
积分子起来的话
就是一个派分之C
那个C就取决于你的这个多少部分的能量
进来对吧
这个大家有兴趣可以记一下
其实非常的简单
这个这里面当然需要一点点的这个
微积分的那个支持啊
但是呢还有另外一个很著名的part
就是哎反射的一部分
它引入了一个著名的叫cook torres模型
那库库托斯模型呢
它的数学公式看上去就很漂亮了
大家可以看到一个很著名的三项叫DF7对吧
这个DFG呢听上去很高端对吧
看上去像什么黑社会的这个标识一样
但其实它每一个字母呢是代表了一种光学现象
它其实也很简单
那这个DFG是什么呢
我先跟大家讲一下D吧
D就是大名鼎鼎的这个normal distribution function
就就是法向分布的方程
它本质上讲的就是这个normal
分布的是更加的发散
更加的聚集
然后呢cook托老先生呢
他就推推推推推推推了一大堆诶
他最后给出了这样的一个方程组
这个方程就现在大家呢normal di图片的方程
大家都会习惯用什么呢
用的这个GX这个模型
GGX4种模型呢
其实数学上那个公式大家可以看一下
其实看上去很复杂
其实就是一堆的这种啊
多项式的加减乘除的运算
其实你真的去SHADER去写
下面我们给了一段尾代码
大家看其实并不复杂
而且这个事情非常有意思的一个事情是吧
就是我它引入了一个RA那个值就会叫阿尔法
阿尔法是什么呢
就是roughness对吧
你们可以尝试一下
把阿尔法设成零时长
0.5
时长一
你算一算那个出来的值是多少
其实呢你不用特别理解他的这个公式是什么
其实练习的课程能讲的会讲的更清楚一点
我觉得我在我这个课程的话
因为我更多的教大家怎么做引擎嘛
所以说大家大概有感觉就可以了
但是呢做游戏引擎的人
我们需要知道什么东西呢
啊这个是当时那个GG那个材料原文中
我个人很喜欢的一张图
他就讲啊那个缝模型诶
高光你看到的是这样的一个曲线图对吧
那么GJ呢是另外一张选图
大家如果在视频上能看得清楚的话
那个绿色的那条线是GG的
这个NDF的那个方程的图
大家发现它的特点是什么
如果用一句简单的话讲
就是他的高频的就突出的地方
大家发现它是不是更加陡
更加尖
对不对
很很尖
但是呢它在低频的地方
就是哎它不像缝模型或其他的模型
快速的就衰减于与接近于零了
它呢还是在往外延拖很久
这个东西如果大家玩音箱的话
我不知道
你们知道音箱里面特别讲究一个东西是什么
知道吗
就是我要买个很贵的音箱
叫高音
要足够的清脆
够高
低音要足够的沉
那这就是个好音箱
它的表现力就比较强
对不对
其实呢当然这是我个人发明的非常粗暴的理解
为什么大家都在用GG这个光照模型
其实它对高光的表达
真的符合这个一个好音箱的标准
就是我要表达那个清脆的
高亮的那个高光的时候
诶你这个波峰足够懂
但是呢当我这个声音是混响
我的光也是混响
你的高光不会消失的那么彻底
如果大家用浮模型啊
你们会发现当我去调那个power那个参数的时候
一调不好
你会看到一个非常生硬的高光的边界线
就特别的硬
感觉就像那个一个物体上贴了个狗皮膏药
但是呢你用了这个cookies模型
你用了那个GG这个模型的时候
GGX这个模型的时候
你发现诶它的过渡就很柔和对吧
所以这个大家如果怎么去理解
为什么行业
你最后大家都用了这个GX模型的话
就用我今天这个非常土的这个比方
就是你买一个音箱
高音要脆
低音要沉对吧
要足够广就完了
这个那这个好的这个光照模型就出来了
当然了
我们得感谢我们的这些理论工作者啊
就是用一堆的数学公式积分简化骇客
最后说
你看最后你用这种简单的数学公式就拿出来
实际上我为什么你们讲个hack呢
因为大家如果仔细读这些推导
你会发现大家做了非常多大胆的假设对吧
那个也就是说real time render的精神是什么
就看起来基本对的
就拉倒吧
你你可以大胆的做各种的猜测和简化
只要不要把这事演砸
你这事情就过了嗯
所以呢这个就是distribution的方程非常重要
而且这里面引入了一个非常关键的参数
就是roughness
就是它表达了你的法向分布的这种随机度
如果roughness越高
它随机性越强对吧
roughness越低的时候才随机性就越弱
他就越聚集越像一个镜子好
你既然有了个随机度的时候
其实呢你就可以得出另外一个东西
就是那个GG是什么呢
就是叫几何这个微表面几何内部的内遮挡
它简单的光学解释是什么呢
就是说哎你每一个表面不是凹凸不平吗
当我的视角看过来
我可能会被自己挡住
对吧好
当我的光射进来的时候
光可不可能被其他的东西也会挡住
所以实际上这里面只要理解一个方程
就是那个GGX那个方程是什么呢
就是说那个叫那个斯密斯那个方程
它是实际上哦对之间的一个方程
他就算了一个东西
就是说我基于微表面的假假
假设你的表面上法线形成一个分布分布的
这个RP分母方程
我给你对你一个假设之后
其实啊我可以用一些积分的方法大致估算出来
你在每一个不同的角度
我有多少的光会被挡住
然后而且那个挡住有个特点
就是因为我是全随机的分布嘛
所以说它只和你的这个你这个角度的啊
怎么说呢
就是你的那个垂垂直的
这个就是这个这个这个cos应该是cos
还是sin的投影有关吧
而跟你的如果你是一个各项匀质的材质的话
我跟你的朝向是没有关系的对吧
那好我对你的视线的阻挡是满足这个分布的
对不对
如果你是个均匀分啊
你这个随机分布的话
其实你的光过来也是一样的
所以你会发现诶他最后GGX材质的话呢
他就耍个流氓
他说诶我把光这个算一遍
你的阻挡性
再把视线算一遍
阻挡性
我就知道有多少的光从入射的这个表面
到弹给我的时候全部被挡掉了
这里面最最简单的解释一下
比如说啊啊一个光百分之百的能量射进来
我根据你的normal碎片方程
就是你的roughness
我知道比如说30%的光被挡住了
那我知道我剩下来的是多少
70%好
这些光呢又是无数的光子
开始往眼睛里面去跑的时候
因为这个分布是isotropic的
就是各项同性的诶
又有70%中的30%被干翻了对吧
所以最后流到我这儿的就多少呢
应该是啊70%再乘70%
应该是49%的光到我这儿来了
它其实就这么一个简单的原理
但是它这个公式很妙的一个地方是什么呢
就是我们在算那个它的这个D的
就是normal的实现方程
我们引入了一个阿尔法这个参数的时候
它又完美的直接用在了这个G的这个选项
所以你就只要设置一个参数
就是roughness
你就能得到两个结果好
那第三个那就是大名鼎鼎的FNOL对吧
FNOL就费尼尔现象
我相信很多同学都已经啊
如果学习过图形学的话
或者说上过图形学相关的课程的话
再次提我的师弟另起的课啊
那他讲的很很通透
大家不用担心讲的很清楚
如果实在大家想不清楚
过两天天很热
大家去柏油马路对吧
站在路上晒一下午
你看到远处的路面上出现了那个车的倒影
你就知道了哦
那就是FNOL的这个效果
简单来讲
就是说当你的眼睛的视线非常非常的
这个靠近那个表面的那个这个切线方向的时候
它的反射系数会急剧的增加
然后呢这个时候你就会产生这种倒影的效果
就是我们的海市蜃楼的啊
当然这不是海蜃楼的成因啊
海蜃楼它更复杂
它空气的密度是不一样
我们不展开
但是的话肥料的话
它本身它就能让你看到这样的一个倒影的效果
那么其实呢
它其实也是可以用微表面的方程去推出来的
但是呢这件事情我还是要感谢这些理论的
这个这个图形学的这些研究工作者
他们就直接给了一个说哎
你把这个参数给个参数
你自己调
然后呢比如说你是非金属
你是金属
你是什么材质
这个数值范围是多少
我就告诉你了
然后呢给了我一个很著名的叫做五次方
我记得从我开始学图形学的时候
我就一直在问为什么是五次方对吧
然后呢老师就会告诉我说
嗯这个是人家推出来的
然后呢我就默默的相信了
直到今天我自己我我得坦诚啊
我还没有推导过我
我我觉得我以
我现在已经把大学的数学还了一半
给我的老师的这个这个现状的话
我觉得我得好先复习一下我的数学
才能推得出来
反正就是说大家记住了
这里面有个大牛推出来
这是个五次方
好这个方程完美了
所以大家发现就是说诶
这个时候COTAS这么复杂的一个反射方程
实际上我只要用一个roughness这一个参数
阿尔法
再加上一个FNOL参数
我就能够非常符合物理的基础
假设的去表达一个材质
所以这件事情真的是非常的了不起
所以这种工作啊
他他是能够上这个这个很好的这个paper的
cotton上这个paper
但是呢很遗憾
就是一些其他的一些方程的话
好像我没看到他能上上C挂在C其实蛮难
就是对rendering其实不是特别友好
我待会儿会跟大家讲这个问题好
所以那其实呢
我们的计算机的这个引擎的工作者
其实包括我们的这个就是做动画电影的工作者
我们就做了一个非常了不起的工作
就是这是著名的这个就是那个MRER这个lap
这个lab是非常了不起的
这个我如果没记错的话
是在德国吧
还是在欧洲的一个地方
他们做了这套设备
不一定是那个设备
但是这是一个很经典的
这个就是b r d f measure的这个设备
就是光啊
和他的那个就是摄像机的角度一直在变
然后我就把这个所有的真实的材质给裁出来了
因为我这样踩出来之后啊
我就可以告诉艺术家说
你对不同的材质
你的阿尔法你就是你的rough
你该怎么设置
你的这个就是啊你的FNOL该怎么设置对吧
包括你的diffuse应该是多少
这次其实这其实真的是一件非常了不起的事情
那么当我们有了这样这么多感性认识的时候
我记得当时我在做啊
刚刚进3A行业的时候
我们其实那时候用的就是CUTORS模型
那时候我们已经不用不用不LIN缝了
也不LPHONE
其实3A行业很早就不用了
但是的话呢
事实上
那个时候普通人的模型真的是有很多问题的
就是artist经常会把它用的
怎么说呢
就是匪夷所思对吧
你会经常看到很奇怪的bug
特别是刚才我们讲了吗
就是说如果你的能量没做好
不守恒的话
那么这个light map就直接炸掉就死给你看
然后你就开始去调
你说为什么怎么回事
因为light map它会模拟光的来回的BING
你就会死掉了
那么这个时候实际上的话呢
我们这里面要引入一个大神
这个这位老哥也是我非常敬佩的一个老哥嘛
就是迪士尼提出了这个BRDF的principle
最著名的迪士尼那个信条
他中间讲了几个点
为什么我今天就是作为游戏引擎课
我会把这个东西再开了
其实这个老哥呢迪士尼是在做动画电影的时候
他们首先引入了就是PB2
基于物理的材质
但是呢他提出了几个信条
这个信条呢
我认为是跟游戏引擎设计的理念是高度相关的
他比如讲了第一条
他说每一个参数它必须要符合艺术家的直觉
对吧
就艺术家不能不懂
你不能够用
这个就是说非常抽象的这个物理概念对吧
然后呢
第二个就是说你不能
就是你不能像做一个理论物理模型说啊
这个东西的它的波长
它的
就比如说你设置你这个材质的反射光波长对吧
那个光那个电子的这个吸收光谱的频率
那你跟艺术家讲
艺术家当场死给你看
他都不知道这个这个游戏
这个东西应该怎么做了
所以他必须要让艺术家能够理解
第二件事情是什么呢
就是说你要尽可能少的参数
这一点真的让我回想起我痛苦的过去
十几年前
当时我们在做游戏的时候
那个材质参数是这么差
非常差
真的这个调到后来自己都晕掉了
你不知道在调什么
经常是你调到上面的
下面的就嘭一下就变了
但是呢它它解决不同的问题
而且呢第二个的话呢就是说他希望是啊
所以第二点说参数要尽可能的少
第三点呢所有参数的值的范围最好是0~1哎
大家想想bin phone里面那个power
就是那个高光的那个那个参数
是不是可以23456789
你你高兴写到100都没有问题
对不对
但是我问那个布林峰
那个100和50和十到底什么关系
你想不清楚对吧
但是这个就是BRENT同志
他就这样说
我们迪士尼的信条是我设置所有的参数
最好一定要0~1对吧
但是呢在有些特殊情况下
我也能允许你超过这个范围
但是呢它必须要有一些有意思的这个结果出来
那么这就是说明你这个模型是有一定的
就是叫创作弹性的
那最后一个也是非常非常重要的
就是说这些参数你去调它的时候
随便你怎么调
它的组合不会产生那种非常诡异的结果
它每一个组合基本上都是有意义的
其实这五条啊你看似很简单
但我在游戏的图形学里面
甚至我在做游戏
比如说做游戏的物理
我在做游戏的AI的时候
我给这些这个我们的designer
我们的artist去暴露出来参数的时候
你会发现事实上你如果能够实现这个五条的话
其实是非常的难的
但是这件事情为什么我一定要去讲呢
就是说当同学们在做游戏引擎的时候哈
呃一定要意识到引擎本质是什么
不是对自然界的一个模拟器
它实际上是一个工具
他的真正的用户是我们的设计师
是我们的艺术家
所以你必须要用他能听得懂的语言
去帮助它来构建他想象的世界
所以所有的复杂
所有的这个困难留给我们自己对吧
把悲伤留给自己
把困难留给自己
把这个快乐留给我们的艺术家和设计师
所以我个人对这个迪士尼信条
是非常非常的推崇对
所以这个这个人的话
我还专门找到他的照片放在这
我们的课程上供起来
这样大家以后下载我们的课件的话
每天可以对着照片膜拜一下
我觉得我我我我
我特别喜欢在课件上给大家讲一些
我们崇拜的大神
因为确实这个行业能走到今天
真的要感谢这些大神
那么基于这个逻辑的话呢
他就提出了一些一堆的概念
实话实说啊
就迪士尼那个那个那个他的P2吗
T2
有些材质属性到今天
引擎支持的也不是特别的好
比如说像那个啊clear coat对吧
我就是表面生成一层木漆的效果
包括shame这种很像抑郁的这种效果
实际上呢就是迪士尼它自身也在一直进化
它的材质模型
但是呢我们的引擎因为我们是实渲染它
它是离线嘛
所以我们一直在追他们
但是呢以及仔细去读他的每一种材质的表达
真的符合他的原则
就非常的直觉
非常的明确好诶
我今天好像时间有点长了
已经一个多小时了
后面还有好多东西啊
我我我想想看我怎么去给大家去加速一下啊
OK这确实今天的东西实在太多了
我们我们这个准备课件的话
这这这一周多干的真的是爆肝
肝没了
但是说实话我们还是对自己很不满意
我觉得课程准备的还是不够好
确实有意思的东西实在太多好
那其实这里面的话呢
我们只有直接直奔主题
就是作为同学们的话啊
因为PB2的知识量很大
那我觉得同学们先聚焦
就现在这行业里面用的最规范的
PPR模型是什么
我们就介绍两种对吧
最主流的第一个就是啊
spector glasses的这个模型就简称S级模型
它这里面的话呢其实它很巧妙的一件事
你就说他几乎没有什么参数
所有的属性全部用图来表达了对吧
我相信很多同学这时候很激动了
对我很熟啊
如果你们用了substance用什么
你们肯定就知道这个模型
这个这个材质模型
那么很简单
第一个defuse to对吧
那么它有三个通道
RGB还有一个什么呢
就是spectre to spectre图控制什么呢
控制它的那个就是说那个他的那个就是那个啊
FNOL那个参数对吧
然后呢第三个图是什么呢
也是RG比较它的free nol是三种颜色
它的free nol是不一样的
为什么呢
当我去表达
比如像黄金
像这种带颜色
像铜这种带颜色的金属的时候
它对于不同的色彩
不同的角度
他的反应是不一样的
这个也是非常了不起的事情
就是被这帮老哥居然给研究出来了
那最后一个参数叫glasses对吧
就控制哎我这个区域到底是更粗糙
更光滑一点
就4G模型的话呢
我认为是一个全模型
它非常的完整
非常的经典
那么而且呢它符合迪士尼的principal
就是每个参数都是0~1之间对比
大家看一下好
那当我踩到了他这些参数的时候
我拿到他的SPEER
拿到他的diffuse
拿到了normal对吧
还拿到它的一个向量
就一个不是向量
是标量
就是那个他的那个光滑度的时候
哎我就可以写一段很漂亮的SHADER了
这个SHADER的话呢具体的细节我不展开了
但是大家可以看他在前面做了一系列运算
比如说他通过GLOSSLESS用一减这个值的话
诶我算出了roughness好
包括我的那些中间值全部算出来之后
大家会发现没有
我就可以带入到前面讲的那个就是AGGX
那个就是那个cot模型里面的那个
就是F那一项
就是那个FNOL那一项
我可以算出他的FNOL那个part是多少
我可以算出他的geometry
就是他ACCUTION那一项我算是多少
我可以算出什么呢
我还可以算出他的那个就是那个啊normal distribution
那个方程的像多少
把这三个项乘到一起
你就能得到它的一个非常漂亮的
COTANCE的反向值
你看这个伪代码的就是第一个函数的最后一段
是不是就三个数一乘
你就能出道你的结果对吧
那这里面当然当然大家真的去写这个这个方
写这个代码的时候
一定要注意
就是有些规划要做
比如说有的要除以派啊
有的要怎么样
这个地方的话呢
在初学的时候是特别容易写错的
我自己最开始在写PPP的时候
我我们其实也是经常会发现哇
这个材质看上去怎么这么假
后来又发现哦
里面某一步运算你知道吗
你整体算错了没问题
它就是变量变换
有的时候你中间有一项算错了
你在很多时候你觉得你都是对的
但是突然在一个时候你发现错了哦
原来里面的某一项
我没有把它规划做一些必要的处理
因为他的所有的数值意义都是积分出来的嘛
就积分你在球面上积分
你最后求出来的那个那个总的那个膜
是个派还是四分之派还是派分之四
whatever他都有有讲究的
所以这个东西呢大家要小心
但是呢如果大家严格地按照书上的说方法
去实现的话
一般问题不大
所以你会发现就是spectre glasses这个模型的话
它很巧妙的一个地方
就是你几乎不用设置任何的参数
大家还记得刚才我们在讲bling for模型的时候
诶你要设置一个诶我的那个这个SPECER啊
我要设置我的这个就是那个啊这个diffuse
这些东西现在全部变成土了
这样的话就artist可以精准的进行像素级的控制
而且他无论怎么控制它
金属的就真的像金属
非金属的
真的就像非金属
就像这边左边的这个球吧
这个案例的话
其实它非常完美的展现了这个PP2的这个power
他的他的这个实力
但是呢这个PP2呢SPECTACROSSNESS模型的话呢
它实际上是有个小问题的
就是说它太灵活了
特别是SPEER那个RGB那个通道
artist呢它一旦设置不好
它就会导致这个FNOL内向就炸掉了
那个那个那个内向叫F0内向
一旦炸掉之后
这个材质啊看上去就非常的奇怪
所以呢在工业界大家后来呢想了一个土法炼钢
说我们研发一个新的模型叫MATIC
Matic
那个那个那个roughness对吧
这个就是mr olic roughness
这个模型呢它就很粗暴
他说你首先设置一个base color
color放在这儿
你别动
那么你呢设置只需你设置一个值叫roughness
就是你的roughness就表示你的粗糙度
这个没问题
我支持你设一个值叫什么叫metallic
这个词其实很关键
这个直接表示叫金属度吧
你可以解释一下金属金属度它的意思是什么呢
就是如果你这个金属度非常低
你不就是个非金属吗
对不对
不好意思
你的这个颜色就不能够进入到他的那个diffuse
那个SPEER那个反射那个项里面去
就是那个那个那个就是FNOL那个项里面去
但是呢如果你是金属的话
你的颜色就会被我大量的抽走
放到这个就是这个free nol内向里面去
所以这样的话F0的话就这里面大家看一下
他其实他的做法非常的有意思
就是说他你可以认为就是说啊
MR2这个材质模型是在cs系模型外面包了一层
大家怎么去理解呢
就是我写个函数
这个函数我写了一个通用函数
非常强大对吧
但是通用函数很强大之后很多人会用用错
比如说我做了一个啊
我做了一个软件
然后或者做了一个app
这app功能很强
大家什么都能用
但是一用用不好会变会把整个操作系统搞炸掉
对不对
嘿那我在外面再包一层小白用户指南
我只允许你这几个开关
你开关变少了
但是呢我会保证你所有的参数都是有意思的
这样我的系统我的系统不会炸掉去
MR2的它的核心思想就是这个思想
然后呢它里面有个ERP
就是根据这个metallic这个值
它在如果你是非金属的话
非金属我就直接把你锁死了
那个值好像很低
我忘了
好像是0.02还是0.3
就是你的base color
就是你的那个那个那个color只能这么多
那个呃那个那个spectra整的那么多
但是呢如果你是这个金属的话
诶我逐渐的就从你的这个base color里面
把你的纸给取出来
这样的话虽然作为艺术家
他的灵活度下降了
但是呢他很不容易出问题
所以其实在现在游戏行业的实践中的话
越来越多的工作室呢
会倾向于用MR2的这个材质
而不是用S级
因为其实就是这
这就是为什么那个迪士尼那个principle
非常了不起
就是说当你管理一个几百人的团队
在做游戏的时候
实际上啊这种可控性反而是非常的重要
诶不好意思
我今天已经讲了将近一个半小时了
不好意思
我争取后面半个小时能结束吧
我们这个这个部分
所以就同学们如果在学PB2的时候呢
我觉得大家重点的学习
就是这个SPECTACROSS这个模型
然后呢接下来再学习一个MR2这个模型
这两个模型基本上够用了
那么包括同学们去经常见到的一些引擎
比如说像那个unity啊
Aria
大家也是这么实现的
那么呃就是刚
其实刚才我已经讲了他们的优缺点嘛
那么当然MR2这个模型呢它其实是有坏处的
它的坏处就在于
就是说当你在非金属和金属之间过渡的时候
它容易产生一个小小的白边
这个白边呢你不注意可能注意不到
但是你仔细看也是能看得见的
这个问题其实真的就是MR2的一个问题
到目前为止的话
我们还做了一些研究啊
发现好像没有特别好的解决方案
但如果同学们如果发现有的话
也不妨告诉我们
那我们马上把引擎改一改对吧
其实这个事情也让我们挺头疼
但是实际上我们的artist的话呢
确实蛮喜欢这个MR2这个模型的
因为MRR模型确实更加的符合直觉
而且更不容易出错
好这就是大名鼎鼎的PP2的这个材质模型
那接下来呢就讲一个更加大名鼎鼎的
就是image based lighting光照
那这一趴呢其实有大量的数学公式
那今天因为时间不多嘛
所以我可能公司会跳着往下讲
就是让同学们去快速的知道他的核心想法
其实他的想法也非常的淳朴
就是那好
什么叫光照
我们一直讲它是来自一个球面对吧
那球面的表达是什么呢
哎它就是一个一个一个一个
就是说你可以用一个cube去表达
他最著名的cube map
一张texture
我就能表达来自于四面八方的所有的光照
如果你把这个cube展开
就是这个十字架这样的图
对不对
大家看那个地平线和天空对吧
你把想象一下一个折纸游戏
你你就算折成一个cube texture
那么IB2的它的最核心的想法是什么呢
就是说如果我能够对这个真实的那个
这个环境的光照做一些提前的预处理
我是不是就可以快速的把它
整个环境对我的光照
和我的这个材质的卷积运算直接算出来
在前面我讲的就是
我们用SAFAMONUX是不是也能表达
对不对
但是呢SAFMX那个表达其实是比较粗糙的
实话实说
它能让你有些明暗的感觉
但是呢达不到我们想要的那种场景的
我们叫做这种细节感和凹凸感
那么而且呢当我们在游戏中去走的时候
你周围的环境一直在变嘛
其实我们是希望特别是主角身上
他的比如说我的光从正面照过来对吧
我背面看到部分照亮了
那还有很多地方是暗部
那我希望暗部也有很多我们想要的这种细节感
这个时候呢就是有个很聪明的人
提出了这个IB2的这个思想
这个AB2思想呢其实讲解来也很简单
就是说大家去看我们的这个材质模型
第二天为大家看到数学公式是不是很头疼对吧
它其实实际上就两趴
一个是defuse的部分
一部分是SPEER的部分对吧
那么刚才我们已经详细讲了这两个函数的构成
对不对好
那diffuse部分
其实大家仔细观察就会发现它非常简单
它本质上就是一个cos函数在球面上的分母
那好对于任何一个就是比如说法向的朝向点
那我是不是给定一个光照的时候
我是不是可以算出来
说这个这个面和这个球面上所有的点
进行积分之后
用cos loop进行积分之后
它的值我是不是可以提前算好对吧
那我是不是就可以直接先算法一个叫diffuse
这个这个它的卷积的结果
这个这个图叫什么呢
叫diffuse erous math
对行业里这个叫法
其实这个词我认为不是特别准确
但是呢它的解法就是说
当我知道了一个环境上的这样的一个一个
一个这么漂亮的一个光照的时候
我知道它的diffusion部分
无论你这个表面上的法向怎么转
比如说以我的身上这个衣服为例
诶
我知道光照过去
我我选一个方向
我去采样
这个就是diffuse unity map
我就知道我和整个这个广场卷积的结果是什么
大家这个又是我们最经典的那个概念
叫什么叫空间换时间对吧
我先帮你把这个这个卷积计算给你做好了
放在这了
你就记住就黑了
那这个东西为什么很重要呢
因为你想我这个空间上的光场采样
我比如说采样一个32×32吧
他也就是几万个点
这个卷积运算用硬件加速是非常快
但是呢当我去渲染这个游戏引擎的画面的时候
实际上我屏幕上是几百万甚至是上千万的像素
而且呢我每一帧都要做
就是每每一帧要做啊
每一秒要做30次这样的运算
至少那这个运算量是非常大的
所以如果这样的话
我这个计算用一张这个小的计算texture
就是其实这已经预先算好的
这个你可以理解成他这个计算表对吧
我查表我就能知道它卷积的结果的话
哎我的速度是不是会快很多
这其实就是IB2最简单的一个思想
defuse也是最好解的
那SPECULAR呢实际上是比较复杂的
今天呢我们本来是认真的去推导一下
今天下午我们还自己再核算了一遍
确保一下我们的理解全部是对的
但是呢这个工程这个工程量太大
我今天就是因为时间确实太长了
我就不展开
而且呃它实际上呢我觉得就这几个公式
没有那么容易讲清楚
但我跟大家讲几个最核心的想法
第一他这个对于SPECTRE的解释的话呢
这个解决方法我们我认为不是特别的这个呃
呃我认为就是它它是一个不准确的一个解法
它实际上做了大量的假设
它本质上是三个方程乘法的积分
它变成了三个独立的这个方程的积分的乘法
这个讲解来有点拗口啊对吧
但是没关系
这个大家理解一下就好了
但是它最核心的一个想法是什么呢
就是我们在这个我们也是把SPER这东西进行
沿着光
沿着这个自己朝向的积分
对不对
但是我不是有个很著名的量叫做RAGHNESS吗
粗糙度嘛
那你不同粗糙度它接记错的结果不是不一样吗
诶它有一个非常巧妙的方法
就是他用了那个硬件上的q map里的meme map
这个功能
就是它把不同粗糙度的结果
存到了这个MMAP的不同的层级
就像大家现在看到的这张图对吧
为什么呢
这个事情是很有道理的
第一个就是说
我相当于我可以在三维空间去查这个数据了
第二件事情的话呢
你会发现粗糙度越高的话
它对光照的这个敏感度就越低
他就越低频的数据
对不对
所以我就可以把它放到mp的最低级
所以注意啊
这是你们的map
不是用mr map
就是俩二合一二合一合出来
他是真的一每一层要单独算出来的
这个大家一定要注意
千万不要写错了
但是呢那而且呢它实际上是一个
它实际上是一个速算法
你的那个你的roughness从0~1的时候
你就可以在里面迅速的去查就好了
那么还有一个值呢
就是这个这个是这也是个
其实这个学名叫look up table
大家如果玩过excel的话
都知道这个概念
就是诶
我把一些计算法的事放在一个look up table里面
我这边输出任何值的时候
他在里面去找对吧
这个logo devil有两个维度
一个是什么呢
哎一个还是你的RPENCE往里往里面放
第二个呢就是你的那个斜角cos theta
记住啊
他只是如果你的表面是这样的
它就是这个cos theta
就是你的这个角度跟这个这个环境的关系
你用这两个词合在一起
这个时候你会发现一个很神奇的事情
就是那个他的FNOL那一项的话
变成了一个线性项
就是放在里面
你就基本上能够模拟cook torren的这样的一个
在这个就是环境光照下的效果
所以这个IP2的话呢
它的这个对SPEER的解决
我个人认为啊
也许我想错了
如果讲错了
同学们跟着我
就是他其实是做了大量的假设的
给出了一个近似解
但是他的很优良的一个点是什么呢
就第一个
他第一次让我们能够在这个
就是说环境光照里面看到了一些高光的东西
注意啊
这个高光不是那种非常生硬的高光
那其实用q map就能解决它
真的让我感觉这个地方好像诶有一点光亮
但又不完全光亮
而且呢它能模模糊的让我感觉那边有东西对吧
这个其实是非常了不起的一件事情
那么所以的话呢这两个方法合到一起
就是一个完整的一个材质在环境光照下的效果
那这里面给大家看个图吧
就是这个左边的话是没有IB2的结果对吧
右边是那个对
右边是有IP
你会发现第一个看上去眼睛是不是舒服了很多
第二个大家如果仔细看的话
你会发现这里面的层次结构很清晰
很漂亮
这个其实是IB2很妙的一个地方
所以这也是为什么十几年前
这所有的3A大厂毫无疑问的全部上AB2
这就是有道理的
他就是
所以其实呢IB2呢
严格来讲是一种光光光照的方法
但是呢就是我们在讲的时候
我们发现我们必须要先把PB2是什么
讲解清楚
我才能讲IBR这两个真的像孪生兄弟一样
就是一下子让我们的游戏看上去真实很多
大家看这边这个场景的话
是不是感觉就很真实
就很有这种感觉
所以这也是3A行业的话呢
就是大家最后总结出来的这样的一个方法
好最后一个就是shadow shadow的话呢
我们今天的话因为shadow它的数学很复杂
我们今天不展开讲
但我只讲解一下
就是说在经典的3A游戏里面shadow几号啊
其实我相信很多同学如果听说过的话
能猜到
其实在经典的这个游戏里面啊
shadow的最主流的解决方法叫casket shadow
对这个这个
这个当时我最早听到这个名字的时候
我就觉得我就想象成一节一节的台阶下去
我脑子里立马出现这个画面
其实它也是非常的简单
就是像我讲的
就是我们的游戏世界越做越开阔对吧
但是呢你从光那边踩过来的沙特map的精度
它永远是不够的对吧
你我方圆一公里
方圆这个就是100米10米
那我都要看他shadow
比如说远处有座山
我要看到它的影子
对不对
近处有10米之外
20米之外有棵树
我要看它的影子
对不对
门前地上放了一把枪
我要捡起这把枪
枪也得有影子吧
你其实这个东西如果你要把山的影子
树的影子和枪的影子全部解决的话
这个shadow就非常的痛苦
你这个精度怎么设置都不对
那诶有个很聪明的人
他提出来了
说我把shadow分成几层对吧
就是他通过你眼睛视锥的方向诶
我在你近处做一个很高密度的shut map
那个sha map的话呢
实际上就是精度很高
但是呢他一般做10米左右
然后呢接下来就是比如说30米的
然后呢100米的
接下来就是2km的更大的这个shadow这样的一层
就是这这边有下面有个图
就是从你人眼看过去
你用的不同密度的
那个绿色的是密度最高的对吧
那个蓝色的是最稀疏的
我形成了这样shadow的这样的一个图
而然后呢我其实这样的话
我这样的话我形成了最后绘制出来的shadow
他就近处看着足够的清晰
远处看着足够的系数
它也符合一个光学原理
为什么呢
因为远处那些shadow他就算有一个边界的话
投影到你的眼睛的话
相对来讲实际上也并不是特别的大对吧
所以它是就是近大远小的原则嘛
所以远处你的眼睛的采样率也是下降了
所以说呢哎你你你眼睛的采样率下降了
我把你的光的那个从光的那个方向
采样率也下降了
怎么样
我们两个就完美的配合在一起了
所以这就是casket shadow的一个简单淳朴的想法
但是这件事情真的非常神奇啊
这么淳朴的一个想法
但真的是统治了这个游游戏行业将近十几年
就是我看了很多的游戏
基本上这是一个最经典的一个学习方法
就是在当然后面一些fancy的东西出来之前啊
现在天下已经大乱了
但是在过去那个时代
casket shadow绝对是王者
那么他有一个经典的挑战是什么呢
就是说你在不同的层级之间
你要做这个差值要做
否则的话呢你可能会注意到一条硬的边界
特如果你不做任何差
你会意识到就是当你的相机推动的时候
你看也有一个固定的地方
那个shadow那个地方会破掉对吧
但是你要做很多的处理
但具体的处理呢都是SHADER
你那些hack
这个hack的话都非常dirty吧
就是说我当年也写过这些hack
所以我个人感觉就是不耻讲出来对吧
这这都是程序员内部的一些小小的这个
黑暗魔法在里面对吧
所以的话呢就是说blend between the casket shadow的话
那就大家如果去写的算法的时候啊
一定要认真的研究一下几个不同的方法和套路
然后呢去看看自己选哪个方法去解决好
那这里面的话呢
其实要讲的另外一个就是这个cos cocky shadow的话呢
它的问题呢就是他要以空间换时间
它的存储空间是蛮大的
另外一个就是说我要生成远处的shadow
其实我相当于把场景给绘制了一遍
那时候你要画大量的东西
其实这个成本其实是不低的
就是大家如果了解一下
就是在就是那个游戏引擎啊
其实shadow的rendering
实际上是游戏引擎里面最贵的一个独立的一套
而且这是让你真的很蛋疼
就是他并不是你真正绘制那种
漂亮材质的组成部分
它只是确保你的光的可见性是正确的
但是呢如果我们的绘制假设是30ms给我啊
shadow很多时候会吃到4ms
甚至到5ms都有对吧
如果在一些比较复杂的场景
如果做的这个比较复杂一点
所以shadow我我自己的经验是
很少能做到2ms以下
对
我不知道其他有没有大牛能做到这个级别一下
反正shadow你想做好的话
基本上是要到这个量级
所以shadow其实是非常非常expensive
尤其casket shadow对吧
你要绘制四次
然后对场景要做四次的这个裁剪
因为你因为你在绘制那个最密的那个shadow的时候
你并不希望他花很多问题
其实你要重新算一次visibility
然后再算它
这里面就一堆的
怎么说呢
就是这个老大说说做做凯斯克沙的
大家都很开心
但是真的去写的时候
发现卧槽无数的这个细节在里面好
那今天的话呢我顺便再说一下
就是其实啊shadow
因为过去给我们这个graphics
程序员带来了无数的困难
所以呢其实我们后来也也想了很多办法
比如说我们就特别喜欢软阴影对吧
做游戏引擎的人都特别爱soft shadow
那么呢就是这里面的话呢
因为今天时间的关系我就不展开了
因为我我我看了一下
就是啊闫令琪的课程的话呢也讲了很多算法
但这里面我就重点讲几个点几个吧
就是说第一个就是大名鼎鼎的PCF对吧
其实PCF真的是个好东西
就是他就是非常scientific
用滤波的方法告诉我们说你怎么去做这个软硬
那么呢基于p cf的话呢
大家实战中用的算法就是PCSS对吧
它呢更精妙
他说哎我考虑一下你到底离光源的远和近对吧
我再用一个sample0
我就能选中shadow
其实这个PCS的话呢
在过去的就现在很多引擎里面都是属于标配
就所以很多引擎里面
你去看他的shadow时长都带一点点软阴影
好像ARRA如果我没记错的话
就有PCS
那么这样的话
你能看到那个阴影是稍微有点软的
那这个效果的话呢
实际上就能够极大地缓解我们的这个shadow的
这个alias对吧
OK不好意思
我讲课讲的比较忙
所以没空看大家的弹幕
到时候我统一回答大家的问题
因为我现在赶时间
我希望我发现我已经讲了一小时40分钟了
争取两小时学习是结束战斗吧
所以这个我们的games课程的这个传统
是什么叫拖堂
然后呢我在前面一直控制的很好
但自从一到图形学这一趴的时候
我发现这个就控制不住了
好那最后一个呢给大家讲解就是warrens shut up
那个soft shadow map
这个呢也是就是具体的算法
大家可以去研究一下
我这边偷了令旗的这个课件啊
我觉得他这个灵魂画手画的这张图
是我见过把vs上单map解释的最好的一个一个图
我觉得这个讲的特别好
就一下子讲清楚了什么叫正态分布
什么叫方差的这个概念
所以他简单他的想法其实非常的简单
就是说哎我去用它的二次方
一次方
我能算出它的方差
算出它的均值
这样的话当我知道我一个depth的时候
我其实就有一套数学估计方法对吧
这里面有一个叫切克夫不等式
然后呢我就大概猜到我说我是大概百分之多少
这里面其实是无数的骇客
但是呢你架不住他最后真的work了
所以其实那个virus soft shmap的话呢
实际上很多引擎也是真的在用的
而且实战效果还真的很香对吧
所以大家如果做shadow的话呢
基本上把这些方法搞明白了
根据你的情况去选择的话
就能达到一个你想要的这样的一个结果好
那所以呢其实在上个时代吧
我觉得这也是我今天课程的
主要就是大家可以理解就是当我做渲染的时候
光我一般用LIGHTMAP加light prop的方法
一般来讲很多引擎的这两个方法都会去用
就是在一起它它解决不同的问题的
那么然后呢我去材质的话
大家这个真的就是天下武功吧
一统江湖就是PBR1统江湖
真的这是当今世界毫无争议的王者的存在
然后呢诶我对于这种背光面的表达
对环境光照的表达
大家现在也基本上也一统江湖了
就是image base lighting
所以说你掌握了PP2
PP2只需要掌握两个模型
一个是S级模型
一个是MR2模型对吧
在学会IB2
你基本上光照这这个材质
光照这一趴就够了
然后呢这个时候你遇到最难缠的shadow怎么办
还这个大神已经帮你指出了一条明路
就是casket shadow对吧
这真的是大神
我觉得那那篇paper我还读过
好像我记得好像是一篇CH对吧
我也很奇怪
c graph居然能发这么工程的文章
这个然后呢就是casa shadow
然后呢你再用比如说vs sem
就是那个warrants soft shadow map
或者你或者用那个就是那个啊PCSS对吧
Percentage clothes
Soft shadow
这技术加上一点点那种软阴影
恭喜你
你基本上有能力可以写一个大概呃
5年前到10年前的3A游戏的渲染引擎了
这个基本上可以出来找工作
没有什么太大问题了
但是呢这个后面这1part我会讲的比较快乐
就时代真的在一直快速的变化
因为就是就像我在第一节
第一节课和那个就是在rendering的第一节课
我讲的这个概念嘛
就是说我们真的要感谢
就是这个硬件的飞速的进步对吧
这个这个N厂A厂都很都很努力
得天天掏空我们的钱袋子
然后呢DX十二十二.1
然后VULKAN出来
然后实际上的话呢它极几乎是彻底颠覆了
就是渲染的底层算法和逻辑
这个我真的要这么说
为什么呢
因为他把整个的计算全部开发出来了
就过去我们很多想干不敢干的事儿
他现在在硬件里面我们都可以看
第二个就是它的硬件算力对吧
基于一个WAP
基于一个就是wave
它的算力非常大
而且之前数据通讯同步数据的
就是来回的倒来倒去的非常的方便
所以其实刚才我讲的像light map啊
像light property算法
在最新一代的这个游戏里面
我们真的在这个突破的边缘
所以我在这个就是RNN的这节课
第一节课我讲了一个概念
就是说如果大家真的在这个实践的这个行业
这个领域里面去金砖的时候
你会发现比理论领域很累
为什么呢
因为你要去不断的跟进最前沿的知识和体系
特别是在硬件发生革命的时候
各种新的算法和方法就雨后春笋的就冒出来了
那这里面比如说大名鼎鼎的对吧
叫实时光追对吧
实时光追这个东西
实际上本质上就是硬件提供了整个这个方法
就是诶你可以把三角形扔进去
他帮你构建好一个
我们在这个老早以前反复讲的叫b vs tree对吧
这个时候你输出一个瑞
他就会告诉你说你是hit到一个东西呢
还是什么都没黑到
如果hit到了
我给你回调函数
没H的到
我也给你回调函数好
接下来怎么办
你自己处理
那么实时光追这个东西呢其实非常有意思啊
就是说现在游戏的标配
你的也要有个实时框架
否则你都不好意思说你是现代游戏了
但是呢你仔细看
在现在游戏中
我用我看的比较多的都在用来做反射
就是甚至我我再提一下
就是那个当时那个微软最著名的那个FA
赛车游戏
他当时那个最新一作horizon
说我实时光追的时候
他故意把那个就是那个汽车的那个GG
做的非常的bling bling的
就很多很多的反射
我就说啊大哥你为了卖一个feature对吧
也是也是很用力
所以说呢其实我自己也很很好奇
就是说实时光追这个东西啊
它其实或者叫recasting这个这个模块啊
它能解决的问题绝对不止这个SPECTRE这些东西
或者不只是retracing
实际上我个人认为
它会彻底的改变我们的光照体系
就是real time的格罗布image information
就实时的全局光照
我相信同学们在看那个就是说啊
虚幻五最新一代引擎的时候
大家最震撼的是什么
lumen那个效果对吧
很漂亮
那么实际上呢这就是硬件的能力解放出来了
那其实现在做JI的很多方法在互相的形成
比如说最高效的screen space gi对吧
在评论空间我去快速的形成这些GI
那包括就是说哎我基于有向距离场SDF
我做的这个GI
包括呢我把这个世界分成各个WORKO对吧
那么这个最著名的就是SVOGI
就是那个叫spars这个vocal这个OCRGI
那么还有什么呢
就是这个VXGI
但是现在也是当红炸子鸡
大家都很火
包括还有就是那个real reflective shmap对吧
还有这个什么RTX的GI
听说是大家是眼花缭乱
对不对
那个没关系
这个首先大家建立一个概念
就是说当这些real time的积压起来之后
整个游戏的画面真的会有一次质的飞跃
我个人认为
就是现在作为一个商业级的游戏引擎的话
这个real time的格罗布是必须要解决的问题
而且呢它的解决方案其实并不简单
就是我们在这个课程的这个后面的高级啊
就是后面的有一个专讲
我就讲一些前沿技术嘛
我们会专门拿至少半节课的事情
努力的把这个比如像lumen的技术给大家讲清楚
就提前给大家剧透一下去lumen里面的话呢
它并不是一个单一算法
它实际上是把三四种算法应该是四种吧
如果没记错
四种算法保保这个组合到一起去用
最后能产生我们想要的那个效果
所以其实它是个非常复杂的一个工程问题对吧
但是我个人认为的话
同学们
今天如果想跳到这个图形学这个领域
里面来的话
我是我
我会鼓励大家密切的关注这个领域
因为这个领域真的是蓬勃发展
有大量的前沿的技术和观点再出来
说实话
有时候连我都觉得这个几个月不看paper
或者说不跟大家去聊的话
我都会感觉有点落伍的感觉
而且我真的感觉就是有一个巨大的革命
正在地平线升起来
就这件事情
这个时代已经到来了
那么另外1part呢
就是说在现代的这个3A里面的话呢
就是这种比较复杂的这种材质的渲染
比如说3S的皮肤材质啊
毛发渲染
都在推到了一个非常非常高的一个
一个一个维度
为什么
比如现在毛发渲染为为例吧
现在由于GMRSHADER这些技术很发达
就是我可以迅速的生成无数的细节
而且它光影效果会做的非常的复杂对吧
3S材质的话
我可以用这种就是强大的算力
可以模拟光在那个材质里面的
refection的一些数学结果
所以这也是让这个就是这些东西都变成了可能
所以比如像cs才知道
最近这两年的那个新的方法和paper是非常的多的
所以的话呢他很遗憾
就今天这个课程实在内容太多了
所以没办法给大家去展开
我现在的语速好像也是越来越快了
OK好
那最后提醒大家
就shmap shader map的话呢
传统的CASA的shadow是挺好用的
但是呢我会提醒大家注意一个新的一个方向
就是这是我们前段时间去研究虚幻五的时候
发现一个非常有意思的事情
就是他们提出了一个virtual shmap
这个想法其实呢很淳朴
就是大家如果以前学过啊
这个这个还是还是跪拜我们的john ka这个大神啊
他以前提出很牛逼的概念叫virtual texture
就是说我把这个游戏环境里面
所有的你要用的纹理
全部拍到一张巨大无比的纹理
纹理上面去
那个纹理叫什么叫VERTEXTURE
就是你要用的时候
你就把它调出来用
你不用的时候把那些texture卸卸载掉
offload掉
那么virtual shadow map的想法跟那个有异曲同工之妙
诶你不是要做cask shadow吗
你要做很大的地方吗
诶他先用算法去算说我每个地方
哪些地方真的需要去这个生成式的map对吧
这个山的麦密度到底是多少
我就在一个完整的这个这个虚拟的shut map上
去分配它的空间
然后呢你就一小块一小块TID
去generate你的shut map
当我用camera去渲染的时候
我打出每个物体
其实我可以知道说你应该取哪个沙雕web的值
然后我就反向去取它
这个想法其实是非常的有意思的
而且呢我个人觉得它能够解决
就是那个casket shadow的话
空间的在有些场合下利用率不够高的问题
而且也很废的问题
所以呢这个方向
我觉得如果大家现在做现代引擎的话
我建议大家去关注一下这个
这个这个新的方向好
那最后我花5分钟吧给大家讲一下
这个就是大家可能注意不到的事情
就是其实在游戏引擎中啊
有一个东西很麻烦
就是大量的SHADER
非常多的SHADER
这个里面就是扩一下我以前的老东家那个班级
班级做完destiny之后
这个其实这个项目我也参与了
所以我知道他们讲的这个所有的东西
就是确实是很蛋疼
然后呢他就讲了一个例子
就是说一个关卡
你看过去就是一针下去几千个水准
跑跑出去了对吧
哪里来的那么多SHADER呢
其实有两个源泉
第一个源泉呢首先怪我们的艺术家对吧
艺术家他会做大量的shader graph
大家理解就是每个shader graph
到最后它们都会变成一段SHADER对吧
这个艺术家的想象力是不受你控制的
所以这个SHADER的数量会很吓人
那么第二个的话呢就是我们程序员自己的问题
就是大家去想象一下
就是其实在游戏中啊
各种的限定条件非常多
比如说你这个材质是在点光源下
是在面光源下
是在这个全球光照下
sf server harmonix下
你是单面渲染
双面渲染
你带不带阿尔法是不是一堆的变换
如果你把每一种变换组合都单独写个SHADER
这个SHADER的数量是非常非常大的
所以呢我们一般会写一个完整的SHADER
这个SHADER叫什么呢
叫UBERSHADER对吧
这个词同学们可能听过
然后这里面呢我们一般会用宏定义
去把各种情况给它分出来
那么每一种红灯异
就代表了函数的一种可能的分支
大家还记得我以前讲过
就是那个GPU里面
他呢最讨厌的就是分子
为什么呢
因为比如说一个函数跑起来
它有一个分支的时候
就会导致它的执行的时间长短是不一样的
但是呢他那个GPU采取的是SMT的架构
他希望我1P指令扔出去的时候
结束的时间最好是一致的对吧
所以我们就会把这些所有的分支编译成
铺天盖地的学着
这里面我举个魔引擎的例子啊
就是大概有165个我们手写的SHADER
Template
就UERSHADER它的生成多少
生成7万多个SHADER
这里面我随便截了个图
大家看一看对吧
这个就非常的非常的丧心病狂
但是为什么uber 这件事情是有道理的
因为你想期望那个学着
假设今天我发现了一个bug
我要去改一类SHADER的算法的时候
如果你不采取五本式的这个方式的话
你得逐次的改它
所有可能组合这个很可能就会改错
对不对
但是用UBER的这种方式的话呢
它自动就编译出了各种组合了
所以它是有道理的
但是呢这些学着就是warrens或者叫permutation
其实是现代游戏引擎非常重要的一个
方法论和概念
那么OK
那么最后一个
大家很容易忽视掉的一个问题是什么呢
就是说其实SHADER啊
这个这确实要怪行业
比如说我写引擎
我写C加加语言
我是不care你是用什么平台的对吧
SHADER这么常常用的东西
居然你给我搞了这么多语言对吧
GRSRHRSR对吧
然后apple还丧心病狂的好好的open gl es不用
他非要去搞一个自己的metal
对不对
但是呢所以当我们在做商业级引擎的时候呢
就是跨这个平台的编译其实是很重要的
那么现在的话呢很感谢开源组织
他们做了一个就是spell那个V的
这个这个这个开源的这个第三方的库诶
它能够帮我们在各种学着你们编来编去
包括像那个PLAYSTATION的那个叫p s cl吧
其实也可以编译
所以这个的大家在做引擎的时候
当我们去学习SHADER的时候
我建议一开始就会尝试
把它编译成VULKAN的版本
编译成这个就是metal的版本
编译成这个其他的版本
这样的话就避免你以为对不同的平台
你在单独写一套
因为他的debug起来是很麻烦的
但是呢就是说这个也是很重要的一件事情
所以你有了这个东西
你的SHADER基本上就能管理起来了
好那我今天呢终于这个紧赶慢赶
把我的课程的主要部分集中在这个两小时
讲完了
最后我跟大家讲一下我们的小引擎
pilot的引擎
这个首先非常的感谢大家
就是我们肖引擎的话
上线之后很快就能收到1000
好像1600多个赞了嘛
真的很感动
这我能感受到大家对我们的支持
就是说确实我们呃能力有限
而且呢就是确实我们是使出了我们的吃奶的劲
想把这个小引擎做好给大家
那么而且呢像一上线之后
很多同学帮我们去快速的修各种bug
我们自己那个就是我们的项目组
同学的话也是努力的
就是尽快的把大家同学们提的问题修好
那么的话呢跟德告诉大家一个好消息
就是现在的小引擎版本
终于可以支持mr one的这个这个
这个就是apple的MR2
神奇的mr one的那个CPU的这个这个这个版本了
那么同学们讲了一些编译问题
一些bug问题的话呢
我们这边也会快速的去处理
那么最后呢我我我最近也在想一件事情
就是说啊我们如果一起做小引擎
大家做的很开心的话
我们可能后面会考虑
逐步的把一些就是比较复杂的一些算法
一些东西放进来
就是我想跟大家社区一起嘛
一起做个好玩的引擎嘛对吧
就做一些比较fancy的东西
比如同学们千呼万唤的这个
比如说像什么就算比较简单了
对不对
我们要不要搞个IP2对吧
我们要不要搞一个自己的这个GI
搞一个real time returing在里面
其实你现在这个框架在上面加的东西
并不难的
那么这件事情的话
到时候我们也会跟社区的小伙伴们一起去讨论
因为我觉得这就是开源的精神
这是我们不明第一次跟开源触电
其实真的是蛮有意思的
我因为这件事情对于我们来讲的话
就是我们也希望能够扎扎实实地为行业
为大家做一点事情
真的我们的口号是什么
就是这个课程上完人手一个这个自研引擎对吧
那到时候中国自研引擎大爆发
这也是我们很愿意看到的一件事情
那么最后跟大同学们讲一个坏消息啊
就是呃我们经过慎重的考虑
决定了五一节我们让自己休息一下
真的课程组实在是干豆累爆了
大家今天看到我们的PPT slice的量
也知道我们过去七天是怎么过来的
这基本上就是已经是快爆炸了
但是呢我们会坚持
就是坚持把rendering的剩下两节课讲完
就是然后呢五一节正好那天是小长假
我们打算呢ring讲完之后
请大家允许我们休息五六天对吧
我我我我自己讲
我说我一定要休假了
因为我周末基本上从来就没有休息
没办法休息
因为周一就要讲课
所以周末的礼拜五
礼拜六礼拜天对我来讲就是地狱模式啊
所以其实今天为了备课的话
实际上我们是要很认真的去查很多资料
确保我们讲的东西尽可能的不要犯太多的错误
其实肯定会有是有错误的
刚才我自己讲的时候
我就发现PPT上有很多错别字
我还来不及去改对吧
所以说呢呃我们打算就讲完rendering
这一趴的时候
五一节的时候我们好好的休息一下
请同学们给我们放个假
然后呢
五一节之后我们就开始讲更可爱的动画系统
给大家好吧好
那就今天我课程的全部
那剩下来还有几分钟
同学们有什么问题可以问我一下
再次感谢一下我们的课程组的同学
其实课程组的同学们已经不止这些了
我后面把它名单再再变得更长一点
然后这个同学们有什么问题问我们
哇这个第一个问题就非常挑战
同学们问我说基安未来会怎么发展
我个人认为就是在游戏引擎中积压的问题
随着硬件的发展
可能在未来的5年左右吧
可能会彻底解决掉
也就是未来的游戏引擎
它应该上来就是GI的
就是说比如说我在读研的时候
我特别喜欢一个算法叫风投map对吧
就是那个pd haham
就是STANFORD的一个大牛
大家说他提出的方案
我个人认为是最elegant的一个GI的光照算法
然后的话呢其实我现在一直在想一个问题
就是说哎
哇这个这个东西
能不能现在做到游戏引擎里面去了
我现在看到一些paper已经讲这个事情了
所以说我觉得随着这个就是general computer的这个
这个这个彻底的开放的话
我觉得其实GI已经很明显的看到一个
彻底解决的这样的一个苗头了
对这也是刚才我的课程中也讲到
就是说如果大家考虑未来10年的引擎的话
那既然是一个must
需要彻底的去攻关
去跟踪前沿的一个方向
啊这个同学们问我的问题更专业了
他说云渲染能不能解决卡基亚的这个问题啊
这个问题其实呢是一个
我觉得比较深深度的一个问题吧
我我想我其实这个问题我得首先得承认啊
我想的不够深
但是我确实是想过的
那我先抛一个我自己个人的一个不成熟的观点
就是呃我觉得云渲染的话
如果采取端云协同的话
说不定还真的能解决
卡基亚老先生提的一些问题
为什么呢
你会发现在这个渲染方程里面
有些计算是view dependent的
就是跟你的观察者是有关系的
有些计算呢其实是跟view没有关系的
就是空间上我就要算法的
比如说那个light problem light map吧
包括像那个我刚才讲GIGI
有个很著名的叫SBOGI对吧
就是sparse workworks的那个worker orchestr算法
那这个东西的构建的话
那实际上他构建好一份
你有一一个人去看
十个人
看100人去看
他都是一样的
那这样很多计算机可以share
那这样我实际上就可以把卡基亚老先生的
一些计算就在上面统一的资料
因为我一个人算一次很贵对吧
但是如果我100个人
1000个人
我只算这一次放在这的话
他可能就比较便宜
其实在这方面的话呢
好像如果我没记错的话
有一些团队
一些很优秀的团队已经开始在探索这件事情了
啊有同学们问我的
问这个问题就比较practice
他说游戏里面的动态日夜
怎么去解决光照的问题啊
这个问题呢
实际上在第三节课我们会讲到一点点
这个系统呢在早年有个说法叫做TD
叫tf day对吧
就是你去模拟一下
从早上太阳升起到中午对吧
哎再到下午慢慢下垂
到傍晚出现晚霞
再到夜里面月亮升起
这一套的光照的变化实际上是非常复杂的
这个复杂还不止于此啊
就是说因为你是这个在地球的不同的纬度
不同的气候环境下
你这个光影的感觉是不一样的
其实在以前最早我们在研究这个系统的时候
是要精确的去理解
就是说比如说在极地
在温带
在热带
在在海洋性气候的地方
它会怎么样
但是这个讲解来听说去是不是很玄乎
但实际上如果你要做一个非常沙河向的
而且非常其实这样的游戏
你真的要解决这些问题
其实这里面的话有很多很优秀的文章
在解决这个问题
那这个问题
为什么我们在这一课里面没有去讲呢
因为它实际上你去模拟的光照
你要和天上的就是那个sky rendering
SKYON的rendering是有很大的关系的
因为比如说我说这个天很亮
它不是一个光源
打的很亮就完事了
它周边的那个天它就会变亮对吧
旁边如果有云云也会被点亮
其实那个就是你看一个天球吧
亮的区域和暗的区域它是有个分布的
所以的话呢包括就是呃白天和晚上的光
差别度是非常大的
如果我没记错的话
能差个大概10万倍以上
就是如果你是正午的阳光的那个流明
应该是晚上的月光的光度的好像是上万倍以上
所以的话呢你的这个材质
所以刚才为什么讲PB2
Pb2
实际上他的PBR的light
就是这个就是基于物理的这个light
实际上讲的就是这个道理
就是你敢不敢把真实的这种
几万倍以上的光学参数输进去
你做的结果也是对的
你因为你只有这个东西做对了之后
你才能够做出真实的那种感觉
还有就是那个艾比尔对吧
你整个天球给你的光照
因为天球光照
其实在整个光照中的贡献度并不低的
就是说如果以白天为例的话
如果我没记错的话
这个就是环境给你的光的话
能达到你的光呢大概1/5左右
所以说特别是你走到那种树荫下对吧
走到那种广场不是特别强的地方的时候
那个环境光是非常重要的一个CONTRIBUTER
所以的话呢在这节课里面
我们讲了一些基础的数学表达
但是呢你真的想做出一个
日夜变换的效果的话啊
其实有很多很细腻的东西要解决
对哦对
跟大家说一下
忘了这个今天因为时间我实在太长了
所以不好意思
不能回答大家的太多问题了
有些问题的话
同学们可以在我们的B站
我们到视频上
大家可以问我们
包括我们的很多微信群
然后我也尽可能我们去回答大家
其实很多问题都不是我能回答了
因为为什么呢
因为量太大
就是我们拜托我们的工商公司
跟我们一起来回答
然后呢
另外一个就是那个啊
这节课呢我们暂时不布置作业
因为rendering的作业啊
这个不布置就算了
一布置就很大哈
所以呢我们可能会在整个render结束的时候
给大家布置一道作业
然后给大家更充足的时间去做它
所以这两节课呢同学们只要认认真去听
认真去想
然后呢选去思考和选择你感兴趣的东西
另外呢利用这个时间熟悉一下小引擎
因为一旦开始需要写东西的时候
你就需要知道在哪儿塞入你的代码
这个我经常讲的就是学引擎跟学算法不一样
学习算法你搞懂了原理
你上来就可以去写对吧
你只要下载一个
比如下载一个direct open gl的案例
你改进行SHADER
你看他效果就能出得来
但是的话先引擎的话
你首先得搞清楚
在那个代码
那个那个那个那个那一堆中间
我在哪去塞入我的东西
所以这个地方的话呢
我希望大家都给自己多留点时间好的
那今天的话呢这个不好意思啊
我超支了
拖堂了
严重脱单已经整整两小时了
所以今天的话我嗓子也哑了
所以我今天就先容我告退
然后呢一个星期之后继续跟大家一起比干对吧
我们再去干一个暴涨物理的PPT给大家
然后那个就是一个星期后见那个
谢谢同学们好
谢谢